we got a lot of good news for you guys
get those black pills out of your mouths
the first big story is that a judge has
ruled in favor of Andy no an alleged
antifa members must pay him a combined
300 000 over damages in the Portland
attack so we'll go through that that's a
tremendous Victory we also have an
anti-trump Democrat arsonist who set
fire to a trump sign twice has been
identified reported to the police and
according to Benny Johnson his his
Source says this man has admitted his
crimes we put up a reward to catch this
guy after a local man posted Nest video
footage showing this anti-trump bike
bicyclist setting fire to a house where
he knew he could cause massive damage
potentially take lives and now uh we
caught the guy so that's the the really
really good news there's a lot more in
the big news you've got Donald Trump's
bail being set at two hundred thousand
dollars so we'll get into that in a bit
we're learning more about Hunter Biden
and allegations and I think this is
going to come out that Joe Biden's doj
intervened specifically explicitly to
protect Joe Biden's Administration is
protecting Hunter Biden to put it that
way apparently there was instruction for
this prosecutor not to go after Hunter
and the only way that's possible many
GOP members are eluding is if Joe Biden
himself intervened but we'll get into
all that before we get started my
friends we have a bunch of announcements
first head over to castbrew.com buy our
coffee to support the show we sponsor
ourselves ladies and gentlemen and this
is the best cup of coffee you'll ever
have I guarantee it and I can guarantee
it because it's an opinion statement
that doesn't mean a whole lot but I
really do like the coffee I think it's
pretty good rise with Roberto Jr and
Appalachian nights are personally my
favorite we got hold Bean we got ground
we have the Casper coffee Club well
you'll get you'll get three bags every
month we also have K-Cups available and
uh I I definitely recommend people are
are cheering for our unwoke decaf but
more importantly sleepy Joe people seem
to really really like the Sleepy Joe
decaf mostly because they like the bag
and the name of the coffee but uh shout
out to the Tim cast members for coming
up with that one also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member to support our work directly as a
member you get access to the uncensored
members only shows Monday through
Thursday and as a member if you've
signed up for at least six months or six
months or at the 25 per month level you
can submit questions and call into the
show to talk to us and our guests I also
have a special announcement
um probably due to a lack of proper
judgment I am announcing that I am
committing twenty thousand dollars
towards prizes at a local DIY
skateboarding Jam best trick contest
this is the August 26 12 p.m Martinsburg
West Virginia 10th clocking year
anniversary skatepark Jam music games
food free parking at the Raleigh Street
skate spot with support from Mbox skate
shop I have not uh conveyed this to any
of the people involved at all nor have I
done anything to organize anything
related to this but uh I figure putting
up twenty thousand dollars towards a
local skate event in the area will
probably help attract a lot attract a
lot of people to the area we'll help the
local businesses with how many people
may end up buying food and um I'm hoping
that by offering twelve thousand dollars
for a first place prize at a local DIY
skate Jam a lot of skateboarders from
all over will show up and this will be
one of the coolest events we've ever had
so if you're a skateboarder if you know
any skateboarders and you would like to
have first place twelve thousand dollars
second place six thousand dollars and
third place two thousand dollars and I'm
just I'm telling you that's also like
maybe the people running it also have
prizes so whatever they give too
additionally professional skateboarder
Richie Jackson will be there to assist
in judging at least as far as it goes
with our portion of any prizes and there
will be a lot more prizes to give out in
cash prizes for a variety of different
things we may end up doing it's gonna be
totally random as I've tweeted I have
done nothing to organize this I have no
idea how it'll even be possible but it
sounds like it's gonna be fun this is
August 26th Martinsburg West Virginia
and uh I I hope you come in and hang out
uh okay smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is Lauren
Brown hi thanks for having me here who
are you uh well I'm Lauren Brown I'm a
woman of many names though uh oh sorry
a woman of many names though I go by L
on social media before that I went by uh
some B I know to quote Rachel Maddow
starts with B rhymes with Mitch I can
fill in the blank there I I gained a
small platform on accident really uh in
2020 but putting out reports on covid
numbers and I my platform grew really
rapidly and I just figured I would be
kind of a jerk if I didn't try to figure
out what to do with it so now I kind of
work on Big Picture connectivity and
timeline uh work and do I have my own
show it's called Big Dig energy that I
do three times a week on Rumble and
that's I just do stuff on the internet I
guess right on well thanks for hanging
out should be fun I think we also have
Hannah Claire back hanging out hey I'm
Hannah clerimo I'm a writer for
timcast.com it's the best you should get
all of your news exclusively from that
I'm biased though Ian's here hi everyone
Ian for awesome happy to be here I got
this cool shirt check it out it's an
entire outfit but I'm not sure I'm not
going to show this gorgeous green velvet
it just reminds me of that Jerry
Seinfeld episode where he's like but I
don't want to be a pirate yeah the puppy
shirt the puffy shirt is my own personal
puffy shirt thanks uh hey I'm uh
surge.com the coffee is good I'm having
uh stand your grounds
um a little bit darker roast and I like
but it's really good so far my second
favorite behind Appalachian nights but
I've only tried those I I agree I I
describe it as like a combination of
rise with Roberto Jr and Appalachian
nights strangely it's very this this one
here yeah it's like it's like a mix it's
like a you know it's medium there you go
anyway let's talk about news let's do it
we've got really good news for you guys
uh to start off with breaking from the
post-millennial judge rules against
antifa defendants in default Awards and
you know three hundred thousand dollars
in Damages over Portland attack each
defendant has been ordered to pay and
you know one hundred thousand dollars
I'm gonna be honest with you I don't see
how Andy now collects but maybe I'm I
mean I'm assuming the net worth of these
uh antifa people
probably in the like the negatives so
good luck to Andy but hey it's a
spiritual Victory it is a monetary
Victory and you know it's entirely
possible that many of these antiva
people come from wealthy families they
may have to just write them a check I
hope Andy know takes a nice beautiful
vacation and buys himself a fancy car
the Court ruled in favor of
post-millennial senior editor Andy Noe
on Monday in his Civil Trial against the
remaining three alleged antiva
defendants that had physically attacked
him in June 2019. defendants Corbin
bellia Madison Lee Allen and samich
Overkill shot Deputy that's the name
were found liable by judge synap
cinapolis eye for assault battery and
intentional infliction of emotional
distress each defendant has been ordered
to pay no one hundred thousand dollars
in Damages the virtual trial was held at
the Multnomah County courthouse on
Monday after the three defendants were
found in default for not responding to
the court order to appear at the Civil
jury trial which was held earlier this
month defendants Belia Allen and shot
Deputy that the guy changed his name
apparently to that for that reason were
allegedly involved in the June 29 2019
attack on no in which he was brutally
beaten by a mob of alleged antiva
members they're very careful there with
their uh fear of litigation while
reporting an event in Portland Oregon
the attack was received Nation uh the
attack received Nation but attention and
is most commonly referred to as the
milkshake incident Noah was left
severely injured and was admitted to the
hospital after the attack left him with
significant injury to the brain so we
have a I believe Andy knows issued a
statement saying at a hearing today
regarding three defaulted
anti-defendants in my no versus V Rose
City antifa at all lawsuit the court
heard evidence about the brutal uh 2019
beating I suffered at a Rose City antifa
Event where I was seriously injured the
court found that I was indeed battered
and assaulted by Madison Denny Lee Allen
Catherine Corbin Bella and samich
Overkill shot Deputy formerly Joseph
Christian Evans the court awarded me
three hundred thousand dollars to be
split equally
um among these three attacker attackers
so here's what I want to say as we jump
into the conversation
the reason why these three individuals
did not show up to court and were found
in default they were guilty discernably
guilty visibly guilty in my opinion what
I'm saying is
there's video footage of the attack and
as Andino tweeted the judge found that
they did commit battery and attack him I
think they knew if they go in they may
even be arrested on on criminal charges
but they actually some of my
understanding is they did show up to the
trial to watch after they defaulted they
then sat and and watched the other
people the other people that were being
uh that were on trial were were found
not liable and so this was pushed by the
left as like oh Andy no loses it's a
it's a failure blah blah blah but now we
have the the award to Andino for three
hundred thousand dollars now I know a
lot of people are saying oh there's
crazy stuff going on someone super
chatted already saying that they like
some cop cars were set on fire in
Asheville we do have that story and so
everyone's very very worried but my
friends we start you off today with a
white pill yo and you know one three
hundred thousand dollars so it's it's
not a foregone conclusion anybody trying
to tell you to give up it's over Trump
can win they're wrong they're completely
wrong all of these super these never
trumpers who keep saying Trump can't win
they're wrong got the data to back that
up and we'll get into it but the time
being there you go everybody it's a good
day huh yeah especially when it's a
victory in basically what I would deem a
hostile courtroom right this is
important lifestyle territory exactly uh
I think you're right it's hard to see if
they'll actually ever pay out maybe he
has to get in line behind their uh
student loan debt creditors but there's
a chance and it doesn't matter either
way because they ruled in his favor it
would be crazy to look at the videos of
this attack didn't they mix like
concrete with this milkshake yeah the
left claims they didn't oh and but there
are many reports that they did yeah so
it's a serious assault and if any Court
had ruled any other way we would really
know that that whole city was a lost
territory in my opinion I think it's a
good sign in general too because he was
working with a group a center for
American Liberty that people are growing
a backbone and actually getting you know
involved in litigation and taking things
to the court system rather than just
kind of grousing about it online they
did work with like Simon ativa I love
him uh and also have been I don't know
if it's the same organization but
launched a lawsuit against the center
for countering digital hate because they
keep targeting people on social media
platforms I just I think that that
generally speaking aside from the stuff
with Andy is just a good sign of things
to come absolutely because people have
to get involved and actually take things
again I had uh these lefties are really
angry they're uh they're they're mad
that Andy no actually won they tried
making that claim as I mentioned earlier
that because the judge ruled in favor of
the other two antifa and you know loses
hahaha yeah but we knew and we said this
the reason these guys skipped is likely
because you know there's there's visible
evidence of them committing this crime
against Andy and they're going to lose
in court so by not showing up they lose
anyway they don't waste their time
mm-hmm concern for that judge and this
safety honestly and I had I I have to
wonder you know when it came to the
first jury the the the the uh the lawyer
for antifa actually said I'm gonna
remember all of you right
and they were concerned from the jury
that they were going to be doxxed and
threatened so uh I'm assuming it's the
the judge ordered this but look the
judge had no choice I bet the judge was
pissed off about it in a Portland judge
probably super far left but has no
choice they're in default there's video
they have no way to defend any of their
actions and you know wins yeah I mean
maybe that's good then right like of
course intimidating the jury is bad of
course we want the judge to be safe but
maybe it's a good sign that they were
like we're not even gonna try and fight
this because there's no way out of it
right like there are times that people
need to see that you can push back and
they will cave I think so often because
antifa gets off in sort of easy police
don't prosecute the same way them the
same way they would other criminals it's
easy to think there's no getting around
them they just get treated differently
and it's good to see Andy know win this
I guess I'm I'm wondering what y'all
think is going to happen in the next
year
right we didn't I don't think we've had
a particularly Lively summer this year
it's an off election year so it's pretty
chill but a lot what ends up happening
it's really funny you get these election
years where there's absolute Bedlam and
everyone's like the apocalypse is
happening and then you get an off
election year and everyone's like you
know what maybe I overreact and
everything's totally fine then you get
another election year and it's worse
than it was the previous year so I'm
wondering what do you guys think 2024 is
it going to get nuts uh I heard that
people are want to mask other people up
again so this I think it's covered that
is happening it was this lock this
shutdown stuff that drove people insane
out onto the streets and rioting and
crap so we didn't do it this year we
didn't have the riots let's not do it
again next year I mean I'm in such a
state of Civil Disobedience right now I
have so low interest in wrapping uh
diapers on my face I didn't I got
coveted I killed kovid I feel great now
I don't want to go through this
again so stand with me and let's shut it
down before it begins have a free and
open Society like we're meant to have I
was I was talking about this earlier
today because I I went to Portland this
weekend Portland uh Maine I don't know
about the rest of Maine but Portland
they never got rid of their their uh
covet policies
so they're still in the city when you're
walking down the street you know they
put those banners on street lights they
all say like wear your mask you must
wear your mask and things like that with
cartoon pictures people wearing masks
and uh the crazy story that I told is
the the local casino in the area they
have like one in the whole state well
there's a couple but the one in the area
is called Oxford when you play a table
game these table poker games you're not
supposed to show your cards to anybody
because it gives the players an
advantage because of their coveted
policies still in effect today they lay
the cards down face up in front of
everyone to see so all the players can
see the cards everyone else has giving
the players a massive Edge against the
casino now most people probably don't
care about the casino stuff but I'm just
telling you this was my I cannot believe
that it is 2023 entering 2024 and in
Maine they still have such ridiculous
and extreme coveted lockdown policies in
place the only thing people said to me
is outside of the casino for the most
part everyone ignores the lockdown
measures and I'm surprised the casino
doesn't at least try to get the city to
repeal them or whatever else because it
seems like they would just lose money by
giving everyone else an advantage I just
tell you guys we made two grand we we uh
yeah me and Allison my girlfriend we
played 200 bucks each just that was it
and we walked out with over 2000 dollars
because like when you can see the other
players cards you can calculate your
odds really easily it's like imagine if
the casino was forced to allow you to
count cards and explain to you the
counting of cards you'd just be winning
at Blackjack all the time that's
basically it's like oh I can see that no
one else has any Aces and I have Ace
King it's like I'm gonna bet really big
look at that I won yeah
I mean in terms of what's going to
happen next year I I feel like I would
want to look at the violent crime
statistics which spiked after kovid and
obviously we had our fun summer of love
an election year we'll put probably put
people on edge if they do try and
enforce some kind of lockdown in the
fall like I've heard rumors are going to
then maybe people will be on edge but
generally I think we are actually
becoming more accustomed to violence
right now we're more used to seeing
violent incidents reported and so in
some ways yes there weren't like major
writings the way there were in 2020 on
the other hand uh we are actually seeing
generally unrest in major cities across
the country you don't actually worry
about this Andy no uh verdict is that it
will make things worse and the reason is
who is going to enforce that 300 000
against these individuals these are
these are derelict individuals as it is
so Andy like I mentioned they probably
have negative money there's a moral
Victory here but the reason why I fear
there could there's a potential for
escalation is when antifa realize the
courts have no real enforcement
Authority against people who own nothing
there's nothing that can be done these
individuals we would call judgment proof
now don't get me wrong they may actually
be trust fund babies a lot of these far
left extremists come from very wealthy
families so they may be going mom I have
to pay a hundred grand and they'll like
just take it out of one of the accounts
I don't care who cares and then they
write a check and that if that's it good
and you know gets 300 000 help he buys
himself a Tesla or something but I think
there's a strong possibility these
individuals don't own anything they have
no money their net worth is probably in
the range of like a couple hundred
dollars
so what's gonna happen and you know is
going to have a sheriff come knock on
the door and be like well we're taking
what you do have and then he's gonna get
an old pair of leather boots or
something he's going to get like an
antifa outfit and how much has he spent
on his defense right now he must have so
much money locked up in legal fees
potentially he could garnish wages
do they have wages exactly exactly
that's what I'm saying and so other
antiva could be like hey look nothing
bad happened they didn't go to jail even
though the judge was like yeah they did
it even if they got arrested they'd just
be said Yes again yup so is there if you
don't pay 100K if they're just like no
screw you don't they get arrested no
jail then no they do not held for three
days we don't have better prisons
anymore
nope now what uh what would happen is
like let's say you got sued and you
didn't pay then the court would be like
they'd go to the sheriff and be like
this person's in default default for a
court ordered payment the sheriff comes
and knocks on the door and says like
we're here to collect belongings and you
can put on anything so garnish wages in
garnetuity until it's paid off garnish
wages is is a possibility but that means
these people are getting paid through it
through a an actual like
an actual payroll company or something
it you know that's what I'm saying these
people are like derelict extremists
they're going to get paid under the
table they're gonna go to some Ally in
Portland and they're gonna say you've
got to pay me they're going to go to a
proper business even a McDonald's and
they'll go to the far left extremist
person who works there and be like just
pay me under the table and they're like
you got it maybe not a McDonald's
because there's a lot of red tape there
but there will be like a mom and pop
Cafe and they'll be like don't worry
we'll pay you cash and no one will know
what's happening and then Andy no can't
get into your money I just have to find
someone who's sympathetic to it and
they'll be on board it's not hard to do
in Portland no but we do have more good
news my friends I have another big story
for you guys that happened over the
weekend from the post millennial
suspected Trump one flag arsonist
identified using Strava after reward
offered by Tim Poole Benny Johnson as
well as John Kane the man who uh posted
the video in the first place now I don't
want to identify the individual just yet
the individual who's been named but uh
so I'm gonna I'm gonna uh not post
anything from this just yet but I will
just say there is a viral video going
around where a bicyclist
rides up to a TR a sign someone's yard
says Trump won starts kicking it comes
back later and sets it on fire comes
back for a second time after his rebuilt
sets it on fire again in one of the
videos there's an American flag hanging
above it he tries pushing it out of the
way clearly expressing knowledge that he
could be starting a major fire and he
didn't want to he wanted to move the
flag out of the way but then it just
Falls right back and he shuts the fire
anyway he knew that this fire could have
spread to the trees burned down homes
potentially caused another major
Wildfire but the good news is he's been
identified
and uh we uh so I I had seen the video
that said a thousand dollar reward for
this I offered five thousand dollars
Benny Johnson quickly came out offered
another five thousand and then a man in
California identified the guy here's the
crazy part he was identified using his
Strava bicycle like GPS tracker
so basically these like people who go
for jogs and bike will get this app I
guess and it will show publicly the
route you take somebody found the guys
that tattoo on his arm with like a teddy
bear or something and then they saw him
in a new story got his name and then
they looked up his Strava account
because he's a bicyclist and they found
that he rode his bike in that area at
the time of the arson ladies and
gentlemen we got him dude it's amazing
you had your Strava active while you're
gonna go commit a crime because I used
trouble years ago like probably 10 years
ago even less than that and to have it's
very accurate to where you were to have
that on just to get the claim for how
many miles you did and while you're
committing a crime in the middle of
nowhere I need my miles though now now
this one got some lefties really really
mad at me and they were I got some
messages where they're like why are you
offering a reward for this and I was
like the dude committed arson twice man
the only way we de-escalate what's going
on with all the extremas in the violence
is if there is a neutral Arbiter of the
law that just says you can not commit
arson the idea that there are lefties
being like this man should should not be
criminally charged for this just shows
kind of how far gone we are right now in
our cultural divide yeah that the guy
didn't turn his Strava off indicates
like what did he like where's the brain
power right now about zero people just
committing crimes and thinking they're
not gonna get caught or get in trouble
Justified like maybe he was like this
sign is ruining the neighborhood it's
very long they're insane it doesn't make
any sense it's like a kid that has anger
issues and gets thrown in juvy like
sometimes you just gotta face the music
once to know what you're up against
because the legal system does not give a
and I think we should all be
against arsonists I know that's a strong
stance to take but I'm willing to say
like if you're gonna burn someone's
private property down I think that's bad
we should collectively agree if you went
back twice and you still had it going
just to record the extra mile to get the
extra miles in this accounting that's
amazing I hope the threat of potentially
Burning Down the House and the area
around the fire uh adds extra charges to
this guy oh he's got to get like
attempted murder I mean I don't see him
doing it but there's got to be some
charges so Benny Johnson tweeted that
apparently this guy has already
confessed to the police they came by and
said did you do this he said yes and you
know to varying degrees he may or not
have been crying when he confessed to
having done it I think this guy is so
riddled with Trump derangement syndrome
that his brain is just doesn't it
doesn't work so when he rides his bike
normal guy just rides the bike you see a
sign you don't like it go you roll your
eyes right he loses it completely loses
it and then commits arson on two
different occasions did he know the guy
whose house it was no because that would
make it premeditated nope I can't
imagine getting that mad over anything
you're quite honestly maybe he like I
don't rode past it every day for months
actually is premeditated arson more of a
crime than just on a whim I mean there's
he went back the second time we must ask
a lawyer but you're right going back the
second time shows that he had
a couple days later too it's like he
must have wasn't isn't that correct like
he must have really went home and stood
on it so much he's like I gotta go burn
that thing down wait let me let me play
the video for everybody okay I just I
just wanna I don't look here's the thing
innocent until proven guilty so people
are putting out his name and everything
right now which was the intention my
intention with the reward is what I said
was information that reads the leads to
the arrest and conviction of this
individual I'm not gonna be posting his
name or anything like that his name is
on all the news articles so you can be
easily looked up but
I think the evidence is pretty damning
that identification that's that they
have for him but uh innocent until
proven guilty so here's the video
here here you can see on August 12th he
rides up
just starts kicking it for being a bison
no but here's the crazy thing
no but why is he kicking it he's also
trespassing what yeah absolutely what is
kicking the sign do other than he's just
very very angry wants to break it right
he wants it to be ripped that way people
can't read it as easily but he didn't
even get off his bike he's thinking
about lighting a fire right now as mad
as he's thinking about it yeah it's made
of wood it's August 12th 7 14 a.m I want
to come back he comes back I think that
night
oh no a day later look at this look at
this 4 20 in the morning so see how he
tries to move the flag out of the way he
knows he could start a major fire and
then it just Falls right back it didn't
do anything and he came prepared with a
lighter like oh that's premeditated it's
like a big lighter yeah it's not like a
lighter that you use to like I don't
know smoke or whatever you use it to
start like your campfire Grill yeah your
candles this guy belongs in prison I
love how he runs away he needs to learn
why you don't say well he doesn't want
to get burned surge of course right yeah
it's such a huge fire station so he
destroys it but here's the thing he
comes back several days later to the
scene of the crime so John John Kane who
owns it
fixes the sign and you can see it says
February 18th John Kane issued a
correction saying it's August 18th here
he comes once again 4 20 in the morning
yep same time what the heck he's out
there with the lighter that's
pathological suspicious suspicious he
just blazed yeah that's like a kitchen
lighter so I don't know
this guy's nuts 4 20.
and they offered a 1 000 reward you can
see he had a tattoo of like I think it's
a pig maybe on his arm but uh people in
the shower saying the Pedo Bear from
4chan better no it's not accurate it's
probably something to do with pigs that
would make yeah it's like a pig on it or
something but they found him they found
him because uh what's he doing he's like
riding his bike at four in the morning
that's a biker thing though no no that's
normal that's fine I'm saying but like
then he stops to commit arson on two
occasions so crazy this guy you know
he's not gonna go to prison what's gonna
happen is they're gonna offer him some
kind of plea deal it's a first offense
they're gonna say you know you never do
this again he'll have to pay it fine he
I don't know though arson's pretty
serious but he did it twice and the fact
that he moved the flag means that
instantly he knew if this fire spread
and it took this flag the trees around
it everything could go up so John Kane
the guy who uh uh let me actually I'll
pull up his Twitter
I don't wanna uh
let's see here so here's John Kane and
uh here's a video he posted uh I'm not
gonna play the full video but he points
out right here you can see that
the sign right here
let's see uh it's just a flag attached
to the trees now here's the important
thing about wildfires they travel up
trees and then across the top of them
and that's the point he's bringing up
that this sign is right next to the flag
this guy tried moving out of the way
knowing that if the fire spread up this
it could get into the trees and if it
was a dry day those trees go up it
spreads around and it how many times how
many houses could have gone down because
of it so uh we got them ladies and
gentlemen does Kane have any say and if
this guy gets prosecuted or is this all
federal out of his hands at this so
here's the other thing James Lawrence uh
a lawyer from uh envisage envisage law
yeah we got it right here uh was
retained to file civil suit against this
guy who committed this and now that we
know who he is and that he's according
to sources confessed to the crime uh
well I mean actually perhaps considering
that he's confessed let me pull up Benny
Johnson's tweet and see what Benny said
about this because uh
then I'll we'll just show we'll just
we'll show his name if he's confessed to
it
I'm trying to be careful here you know
trying to be careful it's too hard
because you don't want to jump the gun
and stick the internet on him on the
other hand right just because someone
posted a photo of a guy doesn't mean
that is him from a different area
doesn't mean it's the right name that's
what I'm concerned about that's why I
want the police to be involved first
this would it reduce harm is that one of
journalistic tenants minimize harm man
that's something that needs to be taken
seriously today with all these docs and
crap people saying each other's names
reposting videos of this and that like
minimize harm but uh Benny is very
confident outright saying it is this guy
who did this thing I mean Ah that's bold
uh as we have already shown with like
the post-millennial typically in this
space people are very careful with with
direct statements of fact especially on
criminal activities but for Benny
Johnson to outright say this is it
according to my sources uh the man has
admitted to the crime and we are waiting
to see if the D.A will charge him I'm
gonna hold off on saying his name you
can easily find it Benny Johnson's
reported that post Millennials reported
that John Kane's tweeted out but I'm
gonna hold back because uh if the D.A
brings charges then we absolutely can
say the guy's name for the time being I
think the important factor here is we're
not backing down
this is the legal way to take care of
things it is the peaceful way to take
care of things and you must understand
the the the the uh Democrat machine
going against Trump guys like this they
desperately want a violent reaction and
so when I see these people on on acts
AKA Twitter uh that are either
anti-trump or just like super pro Trump
like black belt saying there's no way to
win the Deep State the Deep state I'm
just like stop listening to those people
the only look this guy has been found
out he's gonna get sued we'll see if he
gets charged and you know just wins won
300 000 against people who attacked him
these are victories you've got Bud
Lights collapse you've got targets
collapse you've got sound of Freedom we
got other new other news we didn't even
mention Richmond north of Richmond
debuts Billboard Hot 100 number one
the highest chart in the world for music
Richmond north of Richmond number one yo
we are winning all across the board the
things they are doing are acts of
psychotic desperation we need to stick
to the legal path we need to make sure
we are handling everything procedurally
and we're gonna win this I also think
that people from this strata of of uh I
don't know of culture will sell each
other out so if one of them commits a
crime then the other one gets ten
thousand dollars to turn them in he'll
turn them in absolutely yeah yep what do
you think would have happened if
obviously if it hadn't turned into Wi-Fi
but if the Trump sign and the flag had
burned would the charge be a hate crime
then like like at what point was he
trying to avoid things being worse by
avoid like he didn't want the tree to
catch fire but also like did he want is
there an implication where he wanted to
avoid burning the American flag well I I
don't think I'm just curious burning the
American flag isn't a hate crime uh even
though he's attached to a political sign
like it feels politics is not a
particular class that's true uh I don't
think this guy intentionally wanted him
to die but here's my assessment of this
man
I'm willing to bet this guy sits at home
watching the news praying for the death
of trump supporters I don't think he
intentionally
I don't think he wanted his arson to
kill anybody
however
take into consideration the hatred he
has and the willingness commit arson and
his feelings are completely irrelevant
he committed a criminal act that could
have resulted in the death of a lot of
people and that's what matters it's so
crazy how people can get so Twisted from
watching mainstream Media news from
watching like too much MSNBC too much
Rachel Maddow too much anything probably
too much Tucker Carl so maybe could
drive people insane too but like the
fear the thought that like a guy can
ruin it all like Hitler didn't do it
alone Hitler did it because he had
thousands of of people working together
I mean to be honest I can't speak for
exactly but it wasn't just like
a guy can can go ruin everything I I
this whole like fear of Donald Trump is
the most it just empowers the demon I
can't
I can't say I wish that I could say this
a little more articulately but it really
really disappoints me and and makes me
nauseated to see how people become
afraid of a single man it's disgusting
and it like it and it neuters people's
ability to create and to become powerful
forces for themselves I've seen it
happen to my friends in La it's just so
depressing yeah but how would you
years of being told if this person takes
office everything comes crumbling to the
ground you know what I mean like the the
language that the media has or
surrounding Donald Trump is meant to
inspire fear and of course this kind of
dorranged behavior is a result of years
of cultivating anger and fear for me it
was not being alive during 9 11 and
having the story fed to us and
like Hey we're gonna go get Saddam
Hussein now and we're like what in the
hell does that have to do with Osama Bin
Laden like watching this the wool pulled
over my eyes I was on guard for when the
media comes out and says and now this is
the bad guy we have a new bad guy it's
going to be this guy and now now this is
a bad thing like I've already been
through the crap I'm not done I'm done
with it but a lot of people I guess just
maybe they're I don't want to say I used
to be one of these people uh what
changed
my parents didn't
abandon me but I used to be one of these
people I used to tweet about well I
didn't tweet I was on I was on Facebook
uh you know making posts about how much
our I would call them our game show host
president and I like I was this person I
was but I was very unhappy with myself
and when I would look to basically any
sort of I watched a lot of like John
Oliver and like thought that being
snarky and kind of sarcastic meant you
were smart which again we've learned
more since then uh but you know when you
would look at at any sort of institution
any sort of media organization and they
would tell you oh this is the root of
all your problems and you're already a
pretty miserable person uh it it didn't
take that long for that to stick uh and
and
I I tend to think about this a lot
because I am terrified that I was 100
caught up in that psychological hive
mind but it was it was my parents that
kind of brought me back from the brink
you know my stepmom she died earlier
this year but she uh she used to just
look at me and laugh when I would go on
some tirade and be like well well Lauren
why do you think that and I didn't know
and I would get so mad at her she would
just probably defensive it's so
defensive and so angry and she would
just keep just be like well why do you
think that and I could not tell her and
that was kind of my help to bring you
out of it but I
it's when you again they're just being
told that's the root of all your
problems everywhere you look and you're
so upset and angry and miserable that
that's easy to go along with when they
were asking you why do you think that
when your stepmom asking that like did
you like one night you're just laying in
bed think like did it snap and you were
like why do I think this what happened
well I can tell you actually uh again it
was my parents continuing to show up but
there was actually one of my I guess
people call it the red pill moment it
was her it was Hurricane Maria that had
kind of leveled
um Puerto Rico and I'm sorry I'm not
smiling about that I'm just thinking
about my stepmom uh but it was it had
like a really devastated Puerto Rico and
I had made a post on Facebook again uh
our game show host president is tweeting
about pro sports players while Puerto
Rico lies and tatters you've been
tweeting about like Colin Kaepernick and
that post on Facebook got a ton of likes
and at the time you know my ego was
directly tied to how well I posted on
social media but then about a year later
uh it came out that they had found
runways full of supplies warehouses full
of medicine and supplies and water and
food and things that it just rotted and
how mismanaged that was and I
someone managed to get that in front of
me and I felt a real deep sense of Shame
and I I directly remembered that
specific Facebook post so I felt this
shame that I did not want to feel again
and having been you know rather wrong
about something and so it's taken time I
think it's certainly still an ongoing
process but it's I would rather take my
time than Get Fooled Again so to specify
to have the Trump Administration sent
all these like resources down there and
then they had they had mishandled it
down there they if you go back and look
at it it really is it was a clown show
you know they were making t-shirts and
wearing them on the news of you know
disparaging Trump and his response he
was they had sent a
a ton of money and ton of supplies I
don't know if these supplies directly
were from the Trump Administration or
from the United States I assume so uh
but it was just a matter of how
mismanaged it all was and how much time
they had spent in front of the cameras
again making getting t-shirts printed in
a you know place that didn't have like
power like when they could have
distributed the stuff like you're
wasting your time doing this sort of
stuff for TV and for clicks rather than
managing the disaster you know response
and I mean I really
I'm gonna try to be very careful in my
phrasing here I I find
single Disaster Response to be a time
where you can really see people's true
colors you know you see the same thing
with the with the wildfire and lahana
and Maui you know I I'm sure I'm saying
that wrong but in Maui because there's
no one else to blame aside from FEMA
response local response
and everyone's kind of pointing the
finger at each other and you know the
fact that they were tying the was it the
disaster relief fund under FEMA they
were tying the refilling of that fund
and replenishing of it which is set to
expire at the end of August they were
trying to tie that to uh they set aside
I think I might get the numbers wrong
but about 14 billion for the disaster
relief fund and then another 24 million
to Ukraine they were trying to tie these
two things together and you really see
where people's priorities are and I
think that that's just
um I don't like that that's how it is
but I think it's an important place to
look you know and direct response to
catastrophe yeah well there's a lot more
happening I want to briefly mention this
story too it's from Citizen Times
Asheville police cars completely
destroyed by suspected arson seeking
Public's help so someone had super
chatted this uh before the show
mentioning it and I think it's important
to bring up
we're not out of the woods crazy stuff's
going on and I think it's important that
people recognize this stuff in two ways
one
yo crazy stuff is happening with
political tensions they're escalating
but also two two cars being burned
doesn't necessarily mean the apocalypse
is nigh so all in all I think that we're
seeing really really positive signs and
the the desperation from the machine is
enjoyable I'm not going to look at this
and let it get me down I hope they find
whoever didn't bring them to justice
this is insane but for all we know it
could be just like a guy who had a
grudge specifically on this department
it could be a guy who mugged a lady and
got arrested and said I'll show them or
it could be far left extremists who are
like we're coming after cops we'll see
but I want to jump to this next story my
friends this one this is fantastic news
ladies and gentlemen from variety rich
men north of Richmond debuts at number
one as Oliver Anthony makes Billboard
Chart history
yo this is Richmond north of Richmond
debuting at number one on the Billboard
Hot 100 chart making the
singer-songwriter the first artist ever
to notch the achievement with no prior
chart history in any form
he is the sixth Artisan Billboard Chart
history to debut a first solo Hot 100
entry at number one following Zayn Bower
Carrie Underwood Fantasia and Clay Aiken
and Richmond north of Richmond is the
first solo written Hot Hot 100 number
one since 2020's heat Waves by glass
animals which topped the charts for five
weeks in March and April of 2022. it was
widely shed in line along with a video
of the beard country folk singer etc etc
here we go what do they say
17.5 million streams and 147
000 downloads in the tracking week
ending August 17th per eliminate a
YouTube video of the song has 30 million
views to date which means he will likely
be number one next week as well uh
here's what I got to say to y'all go to
iTunes buy the song give him the dollar
one dot one purchase for a dollar counts
as 150 streams if he gets I think he
needs 150 million streams and it looks
like he's already got 30 plus 147 000
downloads so multiply that by 150. if he
gets 1 million downloads he will be
platinum let's let's let's do what we
can I think I think rich men north of
Richmond should be platinum I'll tell
you why I'm not a country guy never been
a big country guy but anything that
advances independent culture challenging
the corporate machine pushing back on
Hollywood and these sick record labels
and the entertainment industry
needs to succeed and that's why I mean
just seeing the success of this song the
fears of Bud Light failures of Target
the success of sound of Freedom ladies
and gentlemen this is changing the
culture and winning the culture war and
they know it that's why they're getting
so desperate and angry as they drown
they will start violently thrashing
about and you know what they say when
you're trying to rescue someone who's
drowning not that we should figuratively
rescue companies that are failing but if
you try to rescue them they'll drag you
down with them you got to be careful
about the the massive multinational
corporations in the entertainment
industry and their creepy predilections
and the weird things they promote as
they lose power they will become angry
and violent and splash fervently in
desperation this means you're going to
see more laws being lobbied to ban the
things that we're doing they're going to
say here's what they're gonna do they're
gonna say well we can allow these songs
to succeed because it's anti-union
because it goes where's the music Union
you know where's BMI or asgap or
whatever and they're going to claim that
this is a threat because you know it's
going to allow exploitation blah blah
blah blah they're losing I'm having a
good day yeah I think it's cool I like
when things just organically happen I'm
sort of I'm not a particularly like
musical person anyways but so often I
feel like the songs that are popular
right now are just developed in the
machine for the machine to benefit the
machine and it's cool to see someone
else do something and it have such a big
response I have a confession to make I
actually so I've read the lyrics but
I've actually not listened to the song
yet but I um I tend to be a little bit
apprehensive about stuff like that for
exactly what you said where I think it's
probably some sort of you know setup or
kind of trying to create the feeling of
virality and the fact that that's even a
thing is honestly so weird you know that
they'll try to
come across as being organic I'm not
saying that that is so I've honestly
been a little bit apprehensive of it I
contacted this with uh Miley Cyrus's
flowers which it's it was like a catchy
fun song I guess but it had no kind of
substance to it oh sure and also they
prepped its release by basically hinting
and dropping notes on the tabloids like
she's got scandalous stuff in her
personal life you should listen to this
song and so it was big for a little
while because the industry kind of I
don't know had this gross reaction to
like she's had a troubled marriage and
therefore here's this so here's some
content consuming right and I'd rather
have something like this that is about
values that's about yeah something whoa
I mean we can criticize we criticize all
kinds of things criticize anything you
want to just because I don't like it
doesn't mean that you know everyone does
can't listen anyways I happen to like
this type of music I also happen to
think this was kind of refreshing I
think people are sort of starved for a
little bit more in their lyrics I think
that a lot of country music Roots were
absolutely kind of centered in that sort
of theming too you know or however you
say the word but I will add this I've
explained this uh in the previous
segments we talked about with billboard
but we put out some music and the
challenges we face
the music we make and Independent
Artists are making people who are
outside the machine is that
a major label band releases a new album
that label will go to Pandora Spotify
blah blah whatever they'll say even even
new bands they'll say like hey we've got
a new band coming out we want their
songs on this playlist and what will
happen is the Digital streaming playlist
will be like sounds good to us then some
people are hanging out on a Friday night
at their buddy's house they order pizza
and someone's like I'm gonna put on
Pandora and they choose rock and roll or
rock or hard rock or indie rock and then
this new song starts playing they didn't
look for it it's just on the streaming
playlist that band will get a lot of
play and a lot of promotion and if the
song is good then people will share it
put it they'll save it they'll give it a
thumbs up it'll be played more and then
they crack the billboard lists
for Oliver Anthony he had absolutely
none of that it was pure organic support
for his music and enjoyment of his music
that resulted in him hitting this chart
so if uh there there's one band that I
actually really like one of the songs
they put out and it was the weirdest
thing to see someone with less than a
thousand subscribers no music presence
whatsoever gets signed to a label put
out a song that I I liked but no one's
ever heard of the song failed charted
nowhere but it was placed on all of
these major radio stations and playlists
and I'm like that's the machine yeah
someone's behind the screens Oliver
Anthony not only hit number one but he
did it in spite of the fact the industry
desperately tries to keep people like
him out that's what John Rich was saying
if he was signed to a label they never
let the song on the air no way no way
that's how so many things people don't
realize one one hit wonder is because
their music they kept putting out got
put on the shelf and didn't go anywhere
that happens the same way it's but this
is just modern Paola and that's already
illegal it's just not it wasn't caught
we haven't caught up to like streaming
services oh right yeah so yeah so Paola
is basically pay to play yeah it's
illegal it is illegal you said when you
had radios you get up I think it's so
called a mechanical meaning the rotation
of a record but yeah it's illegal and
everything else except for streaming
services but it'll we'll get there
hopefully so there are people who want
to go and say like go to a radio station
say we'll give you x amount of dollars
if you just put our song on that's
illegal oh but now because they can buy
the song and it accounts for 150 streams
is that the problem uh yes but it's not
it's not illegal on streams right so
that's why it's still illegal to have
like you have what it's called basically
a playlist or who's a person that works
for Spotify in this case and then they
choose your song makes these playlists
I'm sure if you use Spotify you know
what the playlist if your song makes
these playlists they're like old radio
DJs they would be able to select the
track to play the song it's the same
thing as Paola it's just modern day
Paola that hasn't we haven't caught up
oh yeah you know that some celebrities
are so big their songs are gonna play no
matter what so let's say you're a major
label and you've got a new band coming
out and you want to make money like hey
look we spent a hundred thousand dollars
on this album we need to make that money
back you can go to these platforms and
just be like hey we would like here we
are submitting this to the norm legal
channels please add this to your you
know Digital streaming playlist in this
genre
these these companies know if they say
no then what happens is Major label says
well then I guess there's no real reason
for us to keep insert major label
artists playing on your platform and
then they lose money if that you've got
Apple music you've got title you've got
Spotify you've got Pandora you've got
YouTube music imagine if any one of them
lost a major star that would be like a
form of blackmail if the label is said
to Spotify yeah yeah it's still unspoken
they're implying didn't Taylor Swift
pull her music from some platform on
Spotify for a long time and I wonder
what that was really about I don't know
seriously well she let her about it yeah
she did like re-release her music wasn't
that the case like it was because well
the Spotify thing she said she didn't
like the terms and that she felt like
they weren't paying artists enough and I
haven't read it in a long time they
don't uh so she pulled her music I'm
sure she had her own specific reason why
she was like I'm personally not making
enough money but she represented as like
I'm actually fighting for everybody uh
and then the Masters thing is something
else but it is it is crazy how little
you make I guess is the crazy thing
people don't realize you make almost
nothing even on really big songs that
get money and you were part of you were
on the people like you see a lot of who
wrote the song Whatever you get included
on that and you make nothing I've made
nothing when I was working I mean not
enough to survive in my life so yeah we
we uh put out a handful of songs and we
with the few songs we put out we
experimented with different ways to
promote and different ways to to uh like
how we tell people what to do so with
like one song we said hey everyone just
go and buy the song and then we charted
really well now another song where like
hey everyone go listen to the song
listens
don't do anything you make zero dollars
you get nothing and then you are just it
doesn't even matter you can get two
million views plus sales and then three
million views and the sales you get you
you chart you make money streams don't
do anything for anybody nope and
charting is sort of make or breakout
assume for music like that's how you get
like what is if you wanted to support a
local artist was it better to buy their
song on iTunes or is it better to listen
to them 100 times on well here here I'll
simplify it for you are you is is Oliver
Anthony better off with you handing him
one dollar or you taking you giving him
nothing I mean I would assume it's
better to hand him a dollar but I I
guess what I'm coming up to is is it
imperative that artists then go on tour
like if you want to make it as a
musician what do you need to do like yes
for Oliver Anthony if he peeks at
billboard you know number one that's
awesome but then if he wants to continue
but like he can't survive at number one
like is that gonna make him a living
he's gonna have to tour like what are
the next steps yeah that's that's like
the thing if you if you make money like
the idea and the argument for streaming
is that you don't make money on the
stream streaming is essentially your
advertising you're like you're merging
you're not really you make money for
merchandising Selling Stuff uh vinyls or
clothing or whatever and you make money
from touring which is going on tour and
going to different states and then make
money on the tickets coming in you don't
really make money on the actual music so
if if he wants to be he's a millionaire
overnight yeah definitely not not
because of any of these stupid deals he
shouldn't take them but because
I imagine all of these festivals are
going to be like we got to get this guy
yeah he's got the biggest song in the
world and right now he can he can charge
whatever whatever he wants because
people want to see him perform and he
deserves it this is this is natural
talents breaking through the machine
yeah so I want you to imagine this there
is a bunch of angry suits waving woke
signs and this guy runs full speed with
a sledgehammer spins around and throws
it into a giant TV they're all watching
yeah it's a nice visual
that's kind of how I see it right you
know so more of this this is like the
music version of sound of Freedom we're
breaking through the industry people
keep saying to play it well but we can't
I'm not gonna people should listen to
his song no yeah people should know you
should go to iTunes right now and buy
the song yeah give the man a dollar yeah
if you like it and you support the music
go and buy if you if you've already
heard it and you liked it and you didn't
go and buy it like what are you doing
what are you guys thinking about now
because the age of the recording artists
making a bunch of money is kind of
waning you know it used to be in in the
1900s it was like the only time in
history that you'd be able to like spend
two hours recording a song and then it
you could sell it for 100 million
dollars over the next 80 years yeah and
now you don't control distribution
really it was a blip so like is it smart
to make your own music and just let
people download it from your website
from you for 99 cents all the money goes
right to you screw iTunes screw Amazon
yeah no charge
all the all the prestige crap just sell
it directly to your people that's what
it is
music I would say I would say yes but
obviously we want that but the time
being we want to take over the industry
we I want
when young people are looking up to a
musician because they want to be number
one they don't see WAP they see rich men
north of Richmond this is culture
changing this is going to be
inspirational for you for the younger
Generations this also
you've got young people who are skewing
conservative these young men sure fine
they're gonna go that direction no
matter what now all those grifters you
don't like this is how you force the
grifters to get away from the weird
garbage scriptures are not good people
there are many of these people on the
left they accuse everyone on the right
of being a grifter the right has its
grifters yeah they say whatever they
have to say because it'll get them
clicks even when they're contradicting
themselves one example is like if I
agree with someone on the left and say
hey this person's right they'll insult
me anyway because the tribal position
for clicks is you must hate Tim pool
those people will see this and think am
I on the wrong side of History oh I I
better agree with whatever they say so I
can be on the right side of History
that's why the left chance that or they
scream that you're on the wrong side of
History they want you to believe that a
time will come where you will be
ostracized but the reality is they will
be ostracized they're being ostracized
and they're losing their minds over it
it's a good point man there's something
um about the following a crowd like
they're not crowd's not always right but
when a large number of people enjoy
something you might want to ask yourself
is there something to that For Better or
Worse you know but I think that does
wake a lot of people up oh someone Jason
Dixon said there are a bunch of fake
copies on iTunes so
yes make sure you go to iTunes and you
find the actual song from Oliver Anthony
and I'm gonna say this if he sells one
million
come on a million people have heard this
song already
how do we get them to just buy it for a
buck because not only does that make our
good friend Oliver Anthony over here A
Millionaire not really he'll probably
end up getting I think like 690 000 then
taxes come then you might make half a
million of it but make him half a
millionaire it will it'll make the song
Platinum Good Start debut solo single
writer Platinum song yeah get that
little Platinum single you can hang up
in his in his room and then we can all
talk about how we have decided to do
these boycotts buying the products of
who we like boycotting the products of
who we don't like supporting those who
are challenging the industry
and then also I just want to point out
like think about the lyrics of this song
so actually let me see if I have this uh
if I have this one pulled up there's a
is it rain will where is it at
the rain Wilson story oh do we have that
pulled up oh here we go we got it right
here let's talk about this tweet yeah
from the post to Millennial
multi-millionaire celebrity rain Wilson
slammed for smearing Oliver Anthony over
populist Anthem I don't know that he
really smeared him but uh boy do I love
this rain Wilson you guys know you know
I'm loving he was in the office yeah he
played Dwight Schrute right that's right
he said if I were writing a song about
rich men north of Richmond I wouldn't
talk about obese people on welfare I'd
sing about CEOs who make 400 times their
average worker's salary up from 50 times
30 years ago and corporations that pay
zero taxes in offshore tax shelters for
billionaires let me just uh pause right
there and no one would listen to it so
rain Wilson you're an ultra Rich
Hollywood celebrity type
I don't think this song was written for
you I think this song was written for
the working class guy who's expressing
this discontent with a broken system and
guess what
if he wrote the song as you described it
I don't think it'd be number one I don't
think he'd have the biggest song in the
world right now I don't think he'd have
debuted as one of the only people ever
to debut on their first ever single
charting at number one clearly you are
wrong I think that uh Chris Anthony I'm
gonna call I'll call him Oliver Anthony
that's a stage name it's Chris lunford
is his actual name um but he mentions
the the bureaucrats in that song at some
point I don't remember
he also talks about people that are
getting obese on on welfare which is a
phenomenal point because people you can
buy Pepsi with food stamps you can buy
candy and chocolate crappy crappy
like that's so bad for people so so let
me just point this out when Oliver
Anthony says you know if you're five
foot three and 300 pounds taxes should
be buying your fudge rounds
rain Wilson doesn't get this he is the
fat
effeminate man with liberal
sensibilities who's advocating for lazy
individuals to leech off a system for
which the working class work and pay for
and it is the overall majority of them
who do it and when he says yes but if
the billionaires paid their taxes yes
well the billionaires paid their taxes
it would barely account for any of the
tax base this is the lie that crackpots
like rain Wilson and these other fought
up extremists push to convince you to
allow them to gut the system and steal
from you it's the billionaires who are
at fault let's do the math you if you
were to tax I love this this meme if you
taxed every billionaire at 100 and took
all of their money it would account for
a very small percentage of the actual
tax expenditures and it would last you
only a few months yeah what really funds
the system is that if you've got 300
million people and you take a dollar
from them every day you get 300 million
dollars per day
so you're talking about a couple billion
dollars per week two point some odd
you're talking about billions per month
it doesn't matter how many how much in
cash the billionaires actually have most
of their billionaire assets are in hard
hard they're hard assets they can't
actually liquefy not easily so yeah no
Oliver Anthony is correct he's sitting
there saying his paycheck is almost
nothing the Dollar's worthless and
there's some five foot three 300 pound
person eating fudge rounds off of his
hard work and labor and then Rayne
Wilson's like why aren't you complaining
about billionaires bro rain you are
exactly what you describe yeah
it's the it's the ritual the problem yes
you ultra wealthy fat liberals voting to
to gut the salaries and the and the and
the payments of the working class to
then promise to ignorant lazy people
that if they keep voting for you'll give
them free stuff yeah
it's wild to see people like Hassan
talking about what do you want to
talk about yeah see him say this stuff
he says and he's in a mansion in LA it's
like dude come on yeah I I think that
Oliver Anthony makes a phenomenal Point
talking about these people that are sick
on welfare not and maybe he's annoyed
that he's paying for it but also if
we're gonna fix Society it's gonna be
from the ground up and if people at the
ground are sick then they're not going
to be able to fix Society so it's a big
problem eat healthy get your mind right
get your family right then get your your
Society right it's a system that
perpetuates itself though imagine being
on welfare again making eating food that
makes you sick you're then become
dependent on the like the Health Care
system I mean it's the whole I don't
know it ripples out so and then when
they want I think it's someone I don't
know how literal that is so much as like
it seems to me like a metaphor again I
haven't listened to the song though so
oh you haven't heard it yet no I mean
it's fine it's short it's like three
minutes two two and a half minutes
longer three minutes I uh I still think
it's weird that he's like if I were
gonna write a song I would write
if I was going to be in a comedy it
would be way better than I would have
looked in a different direction than you
looked rain in that one scene when you
were talking to Jim I would look to the
left and yeah your posture was good but
it wasn't that good I would add a little
bit better posture I'm just kidding me
get out here help me make this movie bro
and get work it out with Tim because I
love you Rick come on your spirit man I
mean this I think a lot of people have
affection for rain Wilson because he was
sort of unusual his his character on the
office is uh such a big deal and so
interesting and then he himself has kind
of unusual life but this like well if I
had written a song I would have attacked
someone else and therefore you're as bad
like obviously this song is popular and
hitting a chord and if you want to write
a different song great do it but don't
tear down at the points that he's making
out are resonating with people in fact
humble yourself and take away that
people are really feeling a connection
to this maybe you are not aware of
something that you should open your eyes
to I think you know what he's uh he's
playing at Blue Ridge rock festival oh I
think we went we went there last year
that's a great Festival that was one of
the best I've ever been here no those
stages are awesome slip knot or no not
slip not sorry um Gwar guar played
Adelaide Jack Black and Kyle Gas
Tenacious D yeah of course adelit of
sway they had us got us backstage they
tweeted out special guest Oliver Anthony
man oh it's gonna be lit we should go
he's gonna have he's gonna have like
when he plays that's gonna have the
biggest crowd I hope the headline that
because that'll be really good wow does
he have a full band now I I guess he's
gotta kind of whip the band together put
out a statement that was like I am very
excited about this thank you very
Explorer also I don't feel like I'm
quite a good enough musician to like
take on all these things like there's an
element that he is trying to like
deliver at a maximum level to people who
are supporting him same thing with
merchandise too we put out a tweet that
essentially said I want to do things
right I don't want to just go to chop
shop so be patient and he's working with
like a small family owned or like a
local company yeah yeah the music will
stay on the test of time so there's no
rush yeah it's cool although the iron is
you're not right now so it's good to hit
it you don't need to be the best
musician ever this is the biggest
mistake I hear from young musicians that
I've experienced in my life and it
actually translates to almost every
industry yeah so when I was younger I
played a show I played a bunch of shows
played a lot of shows actually and uh
I'm I was like middle middle of the
middle lineup whoever it's called I was
in the headliner I was in the opening
act and I had the room packed it was
like a 150 seats or whatever
I ended up making a couple hundred bucks
I was super excited I was like Wow most
of the songs that I wrote were just like
four chords relatively basic and then I
would sing
the headlining performance was one of
the most musically beautiful songs I've
ever heard and people left the room
yeah and the reason is it's what we call
music for musicians Oliver Anthony wrote
music for people and people want to hear
that music and then you get these
musical theorists who are like here's
how you write a good song because
they're trying to impress musicians
that's cool no by all means like make
the best music ever made arpeggio the
guitar
like really cool stuff and really great
lyrics that are really impactful or
write a song for the masses that the
regular people resonate with that speaks
to them and you are exactly what a good
musician is I'll put it this way the
best ice cream in the world what does
that mean does it mean like you should
consume it because it's good for you or
does it mean it tastes great
because it's what I was always I would
always tell my friends I knew a guy
played in a band it was like weird
experimental stuff and he kept talking
about how big it was going to be and I
was like you know do your thing man but
I'm just going to tell you you're making
like you're making like you know
asparagus ice cream
some people may really really like
asparagus item it's experimental man
we've never seen this before most people
just want chocolate you know so figure
out what that Mass Appeal is if you're
trying to be a famous musician if you're
just trying to be a musician because you
like music and you like the art more
power to you but don't act like you're
gonna be the biggest so this is what I
would say to Oliver Anthony man you are
the best musician because you wrote a
song that people want to hear it's all
matters it's also the ways things that
you mentioned resonation like if it
resonates and that's a literal
vibrational resonance that your voice
produces in other human beings like you
vibrate their bones when they say that
song resonated with me it's because it
actually literally produced resonation
so the voice I mean it's so lost in the
Modern Age unfortunately I want it to be
recovered this text communication crap I
mean it's you want to talk about where
why is there a degradation in society in
any way I think it stems from that
people are texting each other what 30
years ago we would only speak to each
other about so you could resonate it was
fun but I and and the phone loses a
little bit but I agree with you I think
the internet has destroyed community and
particularly yeah right with Twitter and
short text too because people in I love
this TMZ I think it was TMZ now somebody
wrote an article where they were like
Kid Rock is slammed might have been
Newsweek uh over drinking Bud Light and
like with some even claiming it was
treason and then they showed my tweet of
all caps treason which was clearly
sarcasm but no Tim you're always right
over there they don't care that it's
sarcasm no they're just like wow we can
we can sell this fake outrage any
anybody who did a modicum a small amount
of research into my tweets and history
knows that I did not literally think
like there's I don't care Kid Rock drank
this thing
if Rayne Wilson had been able to say the
words of what he typed if there's a way
that I would understand what he was
saying and be like no I get it I get
what you're saying yeah and it would
even be inspirational for Oliver Anthony
to hear him say those words out loud
when in text it just looked like whiny
text I think text can be be sort
of disruptive to the way flow or you
know intonation would yeah exactly would
would deliver a message I will say in
defensive writing there are times in our
history where we've relied on like
letters and written communication and
because you knew that you wouldn't get
the speed that we now have you put a lot
more thought into it right like think of
like some of the best love letters
written of all written of all time or
poetry or or things that we did in the
past I mean even like the Federalist
Papers right people spent time thinking
about what they were writing in a way
that we don't do now because everything
is so fast not that Twitter can't be
incredibly effective for delivering
messages uh but it's just a different
approach to something that we have
become accustomed to I was uh chatting
with my girlfriend uh and there was a
day that we were having just kind of a
subtle argument or whatever we were
texting and I normally will not text
anything if there's a problem
emotionally it's verbal or we just I'll
peacefully you know I'll wait until I
see you and talk to you about it but
anyway we hyped and then like days went
by things were resolved and I went back
in that chat and for whatever reason I
saw the old messages and it started to
work me up again like it it out of
context it was the past it has no place
in my memory anymore we already resolved
it but it's still there in text and I'm
like reading it and thinking like oh did
she mean that when she typed it well and
these other emotions I'm like what am I
doing I'm like you've resolved the
argument you have to let it go yeah it
should have been like like a memory of a
communication it should be gone in my
memory now but because it's literally in
text I still have a copy of it that's
unnecessary and probably very very bad
for brain I've heard other couples say
that when they have a problem they like
to I knew this one couple that would
email each other and be like when I talk
to you face to face I'm kind of
dominated by my emotions so when I can
sit down and write you a thoughtful and
respectful email about whatever's
bothering me I actually find it easier
to resolve I I think that uh there's a
place for both but I think we are going
for speed and therefore uh stripping
away kind of specific and descriptive
language which helps us understand what
the message is behind our written word I
mean written word's been
such an integral part of the development
of society although I guess the written
word for the most part now is very
I don't know stunted and shortened but I
think that probably the closest thing we
have to any sort of really beautiful
long form thing written aside from
obviously is really like speeches that
are written
um like oratory things which people used
to put a lot of time into those too you
know ultimately meant to be spoken right
when was writing invented 6000 BC or
something
relatively new uh writing I think the
the written I think the timeline kind of
continues to expand you know they find
some good because a lot of the materials
they use for writing or were you know
they disappear yeah and it says four
different periods over uh 3400 BC
Mesopotamia there's happened again in
Egypt in 3200 China and 1200 so only 3
400 BC but there's but then how far back
does it go that we don't have evidence
of it but also what's their definition
of writing could it be like that someone
drew a circle on the ground once to
reference something and that is writing
I think it's a language when there's
language involving like right this is
cute and that's when they say okay now
you can like if you were explaining to
someone a thing you saw and then you
made a symbol that represented like a
tree to explain tree you've begun the
process of writing but would a random
person who comes across it and sees it
be able to translate it that's that's
the question let's jump to new uh more
news my friends now we'll get into the
big breaking story from the day Fulton
County sets Trump's Bond at 2 two
hundred thousand dollars the former
president's legal team has reportedly
accepted the bond interesting
former president has received a bond
amount of eighty thousand dollars for uh
allegedly violating their RICO Act sixty
thousand dollars for six count of
criminal conspiracy Thirty blah blah
blah 200k you get the point
Trump may post bond as cash though
commercial Surety uh through commercial
shorty or through Fulton County Jail's
10 program per the Monday bail posting
the defendant shall not violate the laws
of the state the laws of any other state
the laws of the United States of America
or any other local laws per consent bond
order they want to lock him up
that's that's that's where they're going
towards and everybody everybody keeps
telling me like oh it can't happen oh it
can't happen and then it happens they
arrested his lawyers but here's the
bigger picture
Trump's gonna win
Trump can win I don't want to make a
hard prediction but you've got a whole
bunch of outlets now panicking over this
I love this Colin rugg says CNN warns
viewers that Donald Trump has a real
chance of winning the general election
against Joe Biden can you hear the Panic
let me uh let me play this clip from CNN
for you guys Yak University 53 of the
Fox News well look at where the
santhesis and all these posts look how
far back he is he doesn't crack 20 in
any of them so in Iowa you have that 20
plus point lead for Donald Trump that's
actually smaller than the lead we see
nationally where we see these leads of
35 40 near 50 points in this particular
case
of course the primary is one thing if
Trump wins the primary can he go on and
win the general election and we've had
three polls that have come out over the
last week here and I want you to take a
look at how close this race is at this
particular Point granted the general
election is over a year away the largest
lead for Joe Biden is just three points
within the margin of error no clear
leader look at these one point one point
if you go back at where we were at this
point four years ago Joe Biden's lead
with high single digits to low double
digits this is significantly close to
them when we were four years ago so this
idea that Donald Trump can't win the
general election I want you to lose that
idea this race is very very close and
Donald Trump is pulling better right now
than basically at any point during the
entire 2025 and I got one more big piece
of news for all of you
remember that uh news story that came
out that said 12th grade males are
skewing conservative
what age is 12th grade
18 and uh what is the voting age in this
country happens to be 18. hey so how
many how many of these I'll put it this
way young Trump supporters they will
they they not all of them but Trump
supporters famously say they'll they'll
walk Barefoot over broken glass to vote
for Trump
young Democrats won't do that yeah
they'll tweet they'll get likes and then
when it comes to actual voting they'll
be like I don't actually care I just
wanna I just want to likes on social
media I I think what you'll see here is
Trump's going to get a decent enough
boost that is being missed in the polls
among young conservative men between the
ages of 18 and 21. these polls from CNN
are missing this missing these
individuals right now they're not
pulling them yeah let's take into
consideration the polling errors in the
past skewing towards Democrat
that means Trump's probably up three or
four points then add in the the young
vote that they're probably discounting
which is probably going to vote for
Trump
I think I think Trump's on track to win
as of right now we will see there's a
lot that can change we are an eternity
away in political time but I definitely
see a clear path for Trump to win this
one and this narrative that keeps coming
out from the never trumpers who won't
stop whinging and it's so annoying that
Trump can't win just I gotta tell you
man you know with all due respect to
Bill Mitchell for coming on the culture
war and debating I had to unfollow him
right away I didn't follow him before
but I was like you know he came here he
made his case I agree with some of the
points he made him understand I'm gonna
follow him and then after like a couple
hours I was like I have to unfollow him
because it's the most vile and ignorant
nonsense I've ever seen you can make a
really good point about DeSantis being
younger and having tacked and succeeding
while admitting his campaign is not
doing well and still make your argument
why I think he'd probably be better in
the general
Bill does not do that
so I'm just like I can't the the
anti-trumper on the on the left are
actually less vocal as it seems right
now than the than the uh anti-trump in
the in the Republican party you know I
think a lot of the anti I mean um
there's still plenty in the like the
establishment in the media I think a lot
of it has dissipated quite a bit I've
really I observe a lot of rhetoric from
you know leftist circles and a lot of
them are kind of saying you know I'm
just not gonna vote for Biden again you
know I held my nose and did it and I'm
just not gonna do it I think it might
not necessarily be a huge shift of the
youth towards like in favor of trump but
I think it's going to be a pull away
from trying to support it reminds me of
that they can't stand I can only
remember this reference vaguely but that
Simpsons episode where Abe Simpson was
trying to date that old lady and then
she was like potentially gonna date some
other guy and then in the end he was
like pick me who do you watch like I
don't want either of you anyways good
enough for me and so I feel like there's
a lot of Biden voters who are going to
be like like you said I held in my nose
I vote for Biden but this time I don't
want any of them and the Trump trump
base is going to be like that works for
us don't vote Democrat that's what I'm
saying like I think that that will end
up being a larger impact than they
imagined uh although not to go on to a
totally different subject but they do
seem to be ramping up covid just in time
I honestly I'd never observed this for
myself before again I was a little a
little detached and ignorant for my most
of my life and so I've always kind of
heard that you know it's election season
something's ramping up or and it's it's
turned out to be true yeah I think what
I'll do it I think until you start
following politics regularly you think
oh they just say that that's crazy but
it is a consistent pattern that
something happens and I'm not surprised
that covet is uh rearing its ugly he had
strangely enough right now here come the
lockdowns here comes the mail-in voting
here's all the stuff oh yeah we'll see
if the lockdown stuff actually comes in
a full swing there's a couple hospitals
in Upstate New York that have brought
back the mask mandates uh Portland
apparently never got rid of all of their
Mass policies nobody just nobody cares
which is actually a good sign I wonder
how many places there are like that
where all of it's still technically
there and they just but in some ways do
you think that would be a problem
because when they think it's bad they'll
say oh no we have to enforce this it's
we never took it down and so actually
you're in violation here's a fine here
whatever I don't think so I think I feel
like you do need to see it through like
we should repeal all the mess up it's
good that we're ignoring it but we
should completely we need to find out
where it is and like Advocate to you
know
get it get down yeah I guess I can come
up the word for it
um
let me show you this tweet well we have
a little Gap here uh Michael Tracy
tweeted
it's silly it's silly to declare as
foreordained truth that Trump can't win
when the official losing margin in 2020
was 42 918 votes in three states Trump
actually outperformed polls in 2020 to a
greater extent than 2016 and Biden's
support is 2024. in 2024 is much likely
to shrink than grow he's completely
correct this guy doesn't like Trump not
Trump supporter but he's right Trump
barely won in 2016. now the Trump
supporters like to say no he was
electoral major electoral Victory he was
he tons of votes no no it was something
like 70 000 what was it like 80 000
votes or something in three states in
2020 he only lost by 42 918 in three
states Trump does not need to recover
that many more votes when you look at
how bad Biden is doing Afghanistan
really screwed over by Nook freaked
everybody out and now where the economy
is at yeah I just I I don't I'm not
saying people are going to vote for
Trump they're going to be like I voted
for Biden that was a mistake I'm voting
Trump but if Trump gets the same 75
million votes he wins yeah they don't
have the lockdowns anymore and there's
gonna be a lot of apathetic voters who
are like I just don't care anymore yeah
and I think there are a lot of um
mainstream institutions that are aware
of this the other day when it was the
anniversary of the inflation reduction
act I felt like NPR talked about nothing
but because they're trying so
desperately to say this has been a good
presidency good things have happened
we've passed great policies please stop
questioning us please don't doubting us
it's just not there if you have to have
a full-fledged radio campaign all day
long then obviously I don't think it's
speaking for yourself right things it's
about to stay safe no no go ahead no it
speaks for itself though if you have to
sit there and be like no look no look it
should just be pretty apparent you know
when I was making more money than I ever
had in my life and then Trump did his
like tax cuts where it affected my
bottom line you know I noticed that
immediately it was great that was the
only thing I had friends who identify as
like you know very left liberal be like
well I guess this is good I got this
extra money from Trump so and then they
never talked about it again and you love
how they personified it as you know it
was a cut for like Millionaires and
billionaires like no that that was
something for everyone but they just got
more of their own money to take home and
I was at the point in time I still had
TDS so that was kind of did you can I
ask who you voted for in 2020 did you
vote for Biden oh in 2020 no I voted for
Trump okay so in 2016 I uh voted for
Bernie in the primary area and then I
voted for nobody oh yeah because that's
interesting I think there will be a lot
of people who just will be like I can't
vote for Trump but I don't want to vote
for Biden I'm staying home well I think
that I think that's going to happen
quite a bit here and I think that at the
end of the day for the most part people
are going to vote for whoever is the
Republican nominee but I think on the on
the left you're going to see more people
deviating to a third party candidate so
right I think I think we can work with
that yes definitely I think something
that gives me pause at least lately if
we've had James klug on the show before
and he works with Lisa Reynolds right
now he has been interviewing people on
the Santa Monica boardwalk and the
attitude in 2020 was very much
anti-trump the attitude in 2020 is very
much anti-jobiden generally speaking not
as much like oh I'm going to go and vote
to get back at Trump but like I'm I
can't do this anymore like this is this
is cutting into my bottom line it's
because of my life you know my business
will shut down and I'm not going to go
for this it's been the point where
people are like openly saying like yeah
I'm gonna vote for Trump on the Santa
Monica Boardwalk like that didn't used
to be a thing it is now so I feel like
you're right like a lot of people are
just gonna not they don't have like that
drive they've been at home they've been
working and so they don't have the
drives to go and about you know I'm
actually gonna do that like they did in
2020 when I was just like well then you
can think about you know so I think it I
think what we have I just as it just
would be my own two cents I think we
will be able to do a lot better just
because people are not driven to go and
vote right now I think that people
really were paying attention a lot more
to the mainstream media in 2020 which
they were able to capitalize on too
because covid you know everyone they I
mean they were putting up death tolls
like football scores or and people were
absolutely captivated by that they could
not look away and they were locked in
their homes in a lot of instances so
they became like I mean we saw the
absolute Insanity surrounding uh not
Crisco and Governor Cuomo and you know
I'm a cuomosexual people were just
unfortunate but they were going
absolutely now that you've said that
yeah they can clip it and they will put
it on the internet for you oh well great
well that's why it's always you gotta be
careful when you're quoting oh no I mean
I've been a bad do worse it'll be all
right but but people absolutely losing
their minds and talking about how they
had you know uh crushes on Anderson
Cooper and and Governor Cuomo and
because everyone was just in there what
were the Q-tips oh yeah oh my God the
squad brothers are the giant Q-tips and
then my favorite was when the nurses
were dancing on the graves of the covet
dead remember that oh yeah my first one
Andrew Cuomo did a bunch of press
conferences and he wore a polo and you
could see his nipple piercings that was
such a fun covered moment jeez what a
crazy time we all live are you serious
yes look it up there are screens I'm not
gonna do that but a corporate press got
really mad at me when I said the nurses
were dancing on the graves of the covet
dead because because I think that
strikes straight through it was an arrow
right through their chain mail just
ripped right through it found that point
of entry right right in but it's that
Meme of uh the night with the thin you
know he's got the thin strip in his
helmet and the arrow right into it
because
they're claiming oh so many people are
dying it's a tragedy and these nurses
are just trying to have fun and I'm like
yeah you see the one where the nurses
were carrying the fake dead body and
dancing yeah they're dancing and Graves
and they're like uh no no they're not
like that's I'm like are you kidding
there are people who are like uh uh uh
George alexopoulos best artist on the
internet
had this really great comic where it's a
guy like someone's like looking through
the glass at their like dying loved one
and then there's nurses dancing behind
them and then he Compares it to other
situations whereas like people in war
like soldiers are dancing and filming
themselves as they blow people up and
stuff like that we've seen that in
Ukraine so I want to be careful when I
say this because I really deeply and
truly respect nurses in particular
however there's a bit of a meme
stereotype of the mean girl from your
high school becoming nurses and there
are plenty of news stories one recently
and I can't remember the name or
anything about it but it was a nurse who
she had been responsible for the deaths
of seven babies Oh yeah this is um let
be in in the UK just heard about this
today right and there's this you can
play God in some of their minds you know
you hold the kind of Lucy leppy seven
babies what did she do that killed the
babies she injected air into their
bloodstreams or she overfed them or
there's all kinds of stuff she was um
it's impossible to tell the prosecution
presented all these things what you're
saying there's a level of attention that
comes with losing a baby that she like
it seems there's like in this
pathological addiction too but she's
killing her own babies no she was a
neonatal nurse and so it's babies that
are already at high risk they're already
medically fragile you know there was uh
I think three sets of twins because
twins are often born early one set of
triplets that were involved in this
total is 17 children she was ultimately
uh convicted of murdering seven and
attempted murder of uh six more it's
it's just awful and you know the
prosecution and the defense the
prosecution during trial presented this
maybe she wanted to play God maybe there
was a doctor that it seems like maybe
she had some emotional connection to and
that when they'd be like Oh I'm treating
a baby that I'm caring for just died
more attention you know it just makes no
sense at all it's There's real darkness
in the world and the judge you know
there are a lot there's a lot of like Dr
Kevorkian like there's a lot of like
psychos and medicine and you have to
really think about those kind of things
I'm not like against the death penalty
holy and i would support it for someone
that murders children yeah especially I
would I would hope you children you're
supposed to be caring for that's like
the creepiest thing now hold on there a
minute I would be in favor of a death
sentence for a wide variety of very
serious offenses people who kill kids
people who exploit in traffic kids child
traffickers like all the ones you saw in
sound of Freedom death penalty my only
problem with it as a procedurally is I
don't trust Kamala Harris right to be
honest when she tells me that I should
agree with putting someone to death
right yeah like if if there was it's
really tough I won't support the system
but to be fair in the instance where you
catch someone in the act and you are the
crowd of people and they were like
everyone standing before us just watch
this man try to sell a child then I'd be
like we all we're all I I don't need to
trust anybody but myself watching the
guy do it right and then the guy says I
did it and I'll do it again if you let
me go I'd be like okay well that's a
different story
my only concern is the instances where
the person's desperately begging I
didn't do this you're the wrong guy and
it's a Kamala Harris type being like I
don't care and I'm like yeah it's really
hard I mean I think the death penalty is
extremely serious this case is in the UK
so uh at least let me got sentenced to
um I think I call it full life like
Shield friend full term a full term will
spend a complete life in prison uh for
each one of the accounts she was
convicted for murder for uh but you know
the chill so some of the children did
survive these type of killings and they
are severe some of them are severely
disabled you know they're six or seven
six or eight years old because these
happened between 2015 and 2016. there
are times that you know I would not want
to be on that jury because it's so awful
and I don't know that the death penalty
was actually on the table because it
happened in the UK yeah
the point of all that though is like
when you're talking about the visual of
of the coveted nurses holding those I
think about people like Lucy letby thank
you for knowing her name and more
details because you know more than I do
I just wrote about it today for Tim Cass
news you guys go read it but when I
think about people like that and you
think about the different stories of
just really really pathologically
messed up people taking a job in
medicine where that and it comes out
later that they were playing God or they
were like messing with people's lives
because they thrived like I think about
the dancing nurses and how it was all
about Tick Tock clout and you know again
I had to attend my my step-grandfather I
had to attend his funeral on Skype you
know because they wanted to yeah
I had friends who were not allowed to be
with their dying parents no until the
very last moment when it was over and
you think what would it have been like
if you were allowed to have loved ones
by your side nothing makes me I don't
get angry about a lot but that makes me
very angry it's really hard it makes me
very angry indeed if a medical that they
could experiment on the human population
that there'd be like medical tyrannists
that you would why who our government
like our National Guard is here to
protect us from psycho doctors trying to
experiment on our children like yeah
they've done it before they do that to
our military yeah I mean they make them
the guinea pig for all kinds of things
and they've done it with like literal
people like remember
um it's the the thing where they
infected I figured who was but they gave
people like syphilis back in the day
yeah that's right that's right they've
done it before there's president they've
done it before so yeah I think the
strange thing about the dancing nurses
is that they were told by culture you
guys are the heroes ain't doing anything
I'm sure there are nurses who gave great
kids okay they would go outside and clap
every day yeah
but you know how can you stand there and
make a tick tock while knowing that
someone who is suffering and they're
next to you is not allowed to have
visitors like I I don't know what it's
like to work in hospital and I can't
imagine what the stress is like on the
other hand I can say that you probably
could tell that was wrong you could tell
that you were in the wrong being able to
take time to dance for this apparent you
know tragedy while someone is actually
suffering there's like a oh we're gonna
say no I'm not I'm just trying to find
the G Prime 85 comments and I'm just
laughing at all of them as I go oh he's
so talented I have a lot of friends who
are First Responders and do I mean they
like are the first witnesses to some of
the most horrific stuff you'll ever see
and there is definitely a stereotype of
having like dark sense of humor that
really anyone else would probably find
abhorrent but you know that's how you
cope with those sort of things you see a
lot of that with like police officers
too that again respond to like fires and
crime scenes and things like that and I
think that
dancing to cope through your good time
on Tick Tock doesn't quite resonate the
same as like you know someone telling
maybe a little bit of an off-color joke
but you know that they've seen things
that you would never want to see I don't
know I think people have this ability to
like turn off their empathy when it
comes in regards to another person
that's pissed you off they get to the
point and you're like you know what I
don't even care anything anymore about
that person a bug that you're about to
kill sometimes they'll get emotional
like I'm about to slay this bug and then
I'll just be like hold on a second it's
a bug and then I'm like I have no
compassion zero and I feel like people
went with that towards people with covid
in during the lockdowns and all the
shutdowns they were like they are filthy
they are dirty they are other well I
wonder if it's they turn to like well
I'm getting affirmation on Tick Tock and
I need this right now because I'm doing
there's a there was a prioritization of
self over service and of course you have
to think about your own needs in some
regard but it makes me think about I
don't know if you guys have listened to
it but the New York Times just did that
I think it's a five episode podcast
called the retrievals and it's about a
woman who worked at Fertility clinic
attached to Yale the Yale University
Health System and she swapped fentanyl
which is given to women when they are
having an egg retrieval for Saline
because she was apparently addicted to
Fentanyl and so the women went through
these extremely I mean you don't get
prescribed fentanyl for nothing uh these
procedures with no painkiller and while
they were like there was like 70 of them
in total while they were like writhing
in pain on the table doctors like this
is weird this doesn't usually happen
were they like under
I mean anesthetics affect different
people differently and there's another
sedative that goes with it but a lot of
them were just awake and like saying
like I could drive home right now I'm in
so much pain but I am not in any way
medicated I I got it you got it it's uh
here we go this one yeah so this is from
G prime it says I'll miss you Dad I only
wish you want to switch to the full view
so we can see the whole thing there you
go and then uh then the woman's crying
that I only wish that I could have held
your hand one last time and that's all
the doctors dancing there's a bunch of
them actually so this one is a plague
doctor coming into a house and there's
like a woman and someone dying in the
the woman's you know got the plague and
then the plague doctors all start
dancing and then this particularly
brutal one where soldiers are rushing
into a field as an explosion I'm hit
medic and then they all start dancing
because it's so funny man I'm it medic I
like the plague doctor look like they're
in some sort of musical yeah it does
the nurse's dancing was the most
disgusting and vile thing I have ever
seen yeah it was it was just there's a
video of these women and they're filming
as the nurses are choreographing their
dance and then you hear one woman go is
this is why we is this why we can't get
any help yeah
no joke man these people are disgusting
and psychotic I'd love to interview one
of those front line nurses that because
a lot of those people got caught up in
the chaos and were like well all I'm
gonna do is my best I don't even know
what that and so they're just like not
even working 18-hour days dancing in the
hallways yeah so they would break and
then they'd do stuff like that some of
them would some of them would be like
just to keep morale anywhere above zero
but I I don't know some of them might
have been maliciously not I think it's
something you know I think they were all
they're all more obsessed with getting
likes on social media than they were
with actually dealing with the problem
because they were being the mainstream
again everyone was glued to the
mainstream media the mainstream media
was holding up the if you say anything
against the science the doctors the
nurses then you are a terrible person
you're a hero you're a hero in all of
these again like Mean Girls from high
school are like I'm a hero let me put up
my dance on Tick Tock I don't know
people actually live in one of two
worlds
you need to imagine what it must be like
to only watch CNN
for real or MSNBC crazy so these people
sitting in their cubicle locked
apartments in New York City glued to
MSNBC
think outside the world's on fire
people people in rural areas
we came to West Virginia during the
lockdowns because New Jersey was getting
bad because we knew that in West
Virginia you just live your life and do
exactly what you were doing before but
these people in New York that the
apocalypse was here and then you get
these nurses
clearly the apocalypse wasn't they have
time in any capacity to choreograph
dancing
vile disgusting Behavior I worked with
someone who was living in DC but would
occasionally have to drive out to West
Virginia and he would always say it's
like a different world I'm you know
driving only a couple hours and the
attitude this was like 2020 2021 is just
completely different uh in DC it's it's
like everything is ending and in West
Virginia it's like
yeah you know there's there might be
some stuff you have to be aware of but
for the most part life is continuing on
not I mean I'm
blessed to live in the state of Alabama
I love Alabama you know but we're full
don't move here but uh but it kind of it
started to kind of Peter out towards the
end of the summer-ish in most Parts you
know there's still definitely people
still playing pandemic otherwise and
um
most people's mask like if if you did
you know go somewhere and you didn't
want to put up a fire like whatever sure
like I had a like a mask that had
Penguins on it because I'd had it since
like the previous like I guess cold
Diamond like it would be like July and
I'd pull it up but most people are like
pulling these dirty disgusting things
out of their pocket and it's like that's
actually healthy no I think the worst
thing that I saw was a it was a mask
that was a scrunchie that goes in your
hair and you're like your hair's
disgusting like I mean it is you're like
for convenience yeah like what a crazy
but but it went viral on Tick Tock and
so everyone bought it it's like that
literally does nothing so
congratulations it might even be doing
harm probably if there's fecal bacteria
or recirculated bacteria that's probably
the stuff on that you don't want that
breathe you don't want to breathe it in
man really benefited from the pandemic
you know they could sell anything well
no and I I have noticed a shift of
people calling things like pandemic
Behavior you know when you see someone
on I don't know if y'all are I I just
scroll through it because it's
fascinating a little slice of humanity
but you'll see someone saying like my
pronouns are zezims or whatever and
everyone in the comments will be like
this is just pandemic behavior and I
think that there's a bit of a shift in
kind of the awareness like there's some
self-awareness and and like sentience
almost kind of being developed yeah
which I'm really I'm proud of you know
it's a good sign of life I've heard
sorry all right since the one-two punch
of Awakening during covid one was the
covet itself where you're like okay
everyone's gonna die okay I'll shut down
everything about my life oh everyone's
not gonna die okay then what the
did we just do that why can't I reopen
and the other thing is Epstein when it
came out that Epstein was actually
running kids like that just shocked
people to awareness of how how much
things have been pulled over our eyes it
has become so crazy because he was a
convicted child predator at that point
yeah even before that's the thing people
don't realize who's already had to
charge these high profile people were
saying it got a sweetheart deal and they
were like open because of covet people's
years had been open to what was going on
in schools and then the Epstein crap
came out I mean that was around the same
time was that before covet shortly
before that was like a year before
during right before right before correct
but it just everybody was ready to
really let that ruin what that means
that's right he was he well he was you
know found he was found out he was
unaligned yeah the kids
game ended in Minecraft before it
happened yeah we're gonna go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member and then
you can hang out in our members only
uncensored show which will be up at
about 10 pm so in about a half an hour
and if you've been a member for at least
six months or if you sign up right now
at the 25 per month level you can submit
questions potentially be one of our
callers who do about four or five every
night not everybody gets a chance to
call in uh we try to find the most
meaningful and we try to give everybody
a chance but it's not always the easiest
but uh you could potentially be one of
our callers and uh it's one of the most
most most fun parts of the night so join
us let's read
Marcus Bishop says hello from Maine I
hope your trip wasn't too bad here as
soon as you leave the Portland area you
see less of the mask and Lefty stuff and
more of the Trump Freedom stuff I had so
much a lobster and I have never had
Lobster that good yeah it is the lobster
capital of America it's it's
you could just you could eat it forever
did you bring that crab back from Maine
no no the crab was from is Marilyn
crabbed it oh yes see we're in Crab
country in Maryland that's no big deal
you get some of the best crab ever out
here it's the best but uh Lobster up in
Maine wow what'd you guys doing man ate
a lot of raw oysters and lobster nice
just hang up by the water yeah uh we
went on a boat we rode a boat around
that was pretty fun and uh we ate
lobster rolls and then we had raw
oysters and lobsters and I went to the
local casino nice that's what we do it's
like throughout the day it's like we get
breakfast at a hot spot and you know
nice little spot in Portland then we go
on a boat and we ride around then we eat
a bunch of lobster and then everyone's
like okay we're tired gotta put the kids
to bed and then you know for the last
hour or two we went and played at the
casino and I got to experience their
insane covered rules which give the
player a massive Edge and allow you to
win ridiculous sums of money the the
poker the the poker casino games were
always full
and I'm assuming it's because all the
players realize yo like your Edge is
massive when you can see all the cards
and the more players playing the bigger
your advantage gets and they just keep
playing the game I don't know it's crazy
I guess they make money on slops slots
they didn't care uh but then the next
day we just went to downtown Portland
walked around and I was very concerned
about eating about a dozen raw oysters
and then ice cream and then getting on a
plane yeah but everything was okay nice
everything was fine uh so it was really
cool though the raw oysters they have
from all different they're all different
places different sizes different kinds
I've never been big on oysters but you
put like horseradish cocktail and
vinegar on it oh yeah lemon juice yeah
it was really really great probably the
healthiest I've eaten in a long time to
be honest sounds good chilled chilled
Lobster withdrawn butter that's so good
when they're good they're good when
they're bad they're terrible like this
is the worst thing you've ever had I had
one bad one and it was it but it was
only bad because it had shell bits stuck
in it
I'm but I'm chewing and it's crunching
and then I'm like okay I can't eat this
and then I can't figure out it's just
everywhere the whole thing was covered
in so I just spit the whole thing sand
and stuff it's bits of the shell getting
like candy yeah those oysters have a
little Stone in them so be careful when
you bite down yeah let's go slow suss it
out with your tongue get all the stones
because what will happen is an oyster
will have a tiny Stone in the very
center of its stomach sometimes and
they'll digest it I have a lot of zinc
right they're supposed to be good
because they give you a lot of zinc yeah
it's funny that he mentions though the
the what the super chatter said about
how you leave Portland and then there's
a bunch of trump signs everything out
there that's exactly like Portland on
the other side of the country so
interesting fact yeah like a lot of
States
Dynamite chick said antifa set two cop
cars on fire and vandalized A
councilman's Car in Asheville North
Carolina please look into the story who
cares about a sign we have War
we did I don't know I didn't see they
didn't say anything about antifa but
maybe you know because you're down there
old EOD guy says first ever Super Chat
for first cup of sleepy Joe delicious
oh yeah yeah
um I gotta be honest with you guys
I I will be 100 completely honest the
French roast from Casper is it's okay
you know what I mean like I'm not gonna
sit here and say it's good unless it's
good I like the French roast I would say
that if I'm gonna go out like I like it
better than I like the French roast
better than most French roasts I've ever
gotten but it's fair I would just
consider it to be average you know it's
like oh it's a French dress but
Appalachian nights that's a blend we put
together
and rise with Alberto Jr those are my
favorites seriously there's like
Appalachian ice is so good I'm just
chugging the whole thing legit and I'm
like man this is it's too good you think
you'll discontinue certain ones over
time if they don't sell a lot like do
analytics and like get rid of the French
roast or no we just started a new one
just order less yeah my view on a lot of
this stuff is like I don't like how
Netflix operates in that we have a
really big show it's a hit show it makes
money but not enough money so we're
gonna cancel it and prioritize other
things I'm like that's dumb if if we're
selling a hundred bags of say the French
roast every month then we'll just reduce
our orders to 100 bags per month because
the people who like it can still buy it
it's no big deal for us we want to get
them what they need we'll just reduce in
that area and then where the demand is
we will give more so I will say this
Roberto Jr passed away abruptly
unfortunately he died suddenly of a
heart attack
literally Roberto Jr died suddenly of a
heart attack I don't know what happened
and um
the current bags that we have we have a
few thousand of them left they're
actually selling rapidly because of this
we are so we print batches of bags in
about about 5 000 per order but we only
Brew the coffee in a few hundred per
order I think it's a few hundred and we
do that consistently so there's always
fresh in rotation once these printed
bags are gone they will never exist
again the new bags will have a in memory
and loving memory of Roberto Jr on the
back of them
it'll be effectively the same thing but
if you want the original bag from when
Roberto Jr was our star celebrity and he
was alive you got to buy it now before
they run out we're we're doing a special
Halloween blend called re-rise with
Roberto Jr that's got a chicken leg
coming out of the ground and we're only
going to be doing 500 of these and it's
a uh yeah I think it's gonna be I think
it's a medium medium roast I'm not
entirely sure but I'm really excited for
I I think we talked with Alex Stein
about doing the prime time Alex Stein 99
Prime Time grind and I think it's going
to be two times the caffeine that's
awesome that'll be so funny I don't know
and then Sheamus is working on the art
for the Sheamus blend really excited for
all this
let's grab some more Super chats
where are we at Matthew Hammond says
Lauren is the best we should all
remember that black pills are
suppositories is that is that a
reference from you no uh no but I do I
do kind of think that I talk a lot about
black pilling on the show and and just
say you know it's drinking poison and
expecting other people to die it's and
it it poisons the minds of other people
around you like it does not if you're
wanting to vent if you're wanting to
you know have a moment fine but if
you're if that's what all you're doing
constantly you you bring those things
into fruition so I'd have a pretty
that's not like a no black pilling
allowed thing but you know be
constructive with what you're saying or
get out probably with my issues with
venting and text because if you vet with
your words it's done if you vent on
Twitter it's there forever for people to
go read next week and go relive your
Trauma from last week that's out of your
system so like don't vent with text vent
with your words
all right Alan Childers says can I get a
shout out for the birth of my son Joseph
Daniel born 6 45 tonight mom and baby
are doing great I'm going to have to get
him a beanie now shout out Joseph Daniel
Welcome To Earth look at that kid coming
in before IRL so his dad didn't miss the
live show
maybe there's a chance to vent in text
alone in your Journal just don't put
your text vent online do me that favor
not you no I do anyone listening yeah
Thomas happy birthday baby yeah Thomas
Ruff says lost my dog to cancer on
Friday please give a shout out to Rufus
Xavier my beloved best friend of 14
years Rufus what a name this is an
emotional roller coaster yeah really
we're up for now one more time guys
sorry to hear it good Sir Thomas uh
Rufus Xavier is chasing cars up in
heaven
weird nug says 30 500 acre wildfire in
Oregon 881 Personnel on site please keep
them in your prayers wow is there
emotional roller coaster yeah we're
crazy days one of my buddies uh from
Boise from Back Bay is out there right
now fighting fires yes sir wow hidden
Mission says are you going to talk about
the house oversight committee Robert L
Peters Joe Biden pseudonym uh
emails the daily wire is covering
perhaps uh I'll cover it tomorrow
morning
pseudonymous it's it's interesting stuff
pseudonym
that one gamer says I was the one who
recommended inspiring Philosophy for the
culture war on the after show a while
back I was thinking maybe he can have a
conversation with Ian easy to reach on X
what do you say Ian
I it is about time for me to do another
culture War
really good one let's make it a good one
we need to find some good religious uh
Debaters maybe Bill Maher uh because the
writer strike real time's not on air
right can we get Bill Maher to come in
and talk religion that'd be awesome yeah
that'd be really interesting I just
watched about half of him and Vivek
around the Swami go at it on on uh Club
random cool stuff you know I wish I had
been there me too
it's got a real friendly Vibe Little V
for Vendetta quote but uh there was when
he mentions that Donald Trump said if
Wikileaks has the email you know you
know we'd be interested in having a
published or whatever and Bill Maher
took a very like
neolib hyper extreme view of it and
Vivek was like I don't know what you're
talking about and then he was like
you're the no BS guy and you don't even
know what you're talking he said he
wanted Russia to do this blah blah and
I'm like
bill needs to have a sit down with some
regular people you know what I mean like
I think I would love to do a Bill Maher
culture war and then also just get some
like Suburban Metro you know DC area
kind of guys like middle of the road
kind of not kind of angry with the
Democrats and just have him join the
show and talk to Bill and yeah I got the
same Vibe because Vivek kept being like
I'm gonna make the country and bring
people together and he's like and then
bill will be like yeah but Trump I just
want I just hold on before you talk
about making the world better Trump and
your boyfriend Trump was like that was
like the final straw for vague when he
called himek he was his boyfriend he was
like all right dude I'm here because I
want to be his brains are broken and I
was like yeah he's just too he's been
stuck in that political life for so long
so intensely I'd love to help him out
there's plenty of things that you could
criticize with aegon I I do like him
there's some
that big hole I don't know but if you're
if it's reduced down to but Trump that's
not really that's not right that's what
Bill kept people are just dumb yeah it
was like I'm sorry all right Viper 69
says just watched your video about the
queen song there's something you missed
the card is The Greatest Hits volume 1
album Queen's Greatest Hits is a three
album set and I want to break for these
on volume too ah I see I see so I missed
that either way uh the issue is this
there's this thing called the uto player
which is for children ages zero through
nine well they have a nine plus section
but it's like zero through two you know
two to four six to eight or whatever and
for the Queen card it's little memory
cards you put in and it plays it they
removed the song Fat Bottomed Girls and
it generated some controversy where
everyone's like oh they removed the song
from the album it's wokeness it's
Millennials and I'm like dude it's a
kids thing you know but I gotta be
honest I don't know if Bohemian Rhapsody
is appropriate for two-year-olds or
five-year-olds either on the website it
says six to Fourteen and I'm like
I get having like a six-year-old and
wanting to sing Bohemian Rhapsody but I
also think people should consider you're
driving in your car with your
six-year-old going Mama just killed a
man put a gun against his head pulled my
trigger now I I don't know if you want
to be saying that in front of your kid
right yeah that means Grace it's one of
the greatest songs ever if not the
greatest and it's like one of the best
things to sing but I understand why they
took Fat Bottomed Girls off of the you
know they're like we don't want kids
listen to Fat Bottom Girls what a great
song it's similar things you make the
rocking World Go Round that song's so
good I I to be fair though I do think
Fat Bottomed Girls is sillier and
funnier for kids then I put a gun
against his head and pulled the trigger
and now I'm gonna go away for a long
time I gotta face the truth like I think
Bohemian Rhapsody maybe one of the best
songs ever written and it was yeah it
was like
it was it was it didn't exist in the 80s
I didn't I grew born in 79 yeah and then
like never got radio play in the 80s
never got radio playing that's because
and then Wayne's World came out and put
it in the movie and then it exploded and
became a worldwide hit like in the 90s
it was Dave early and actually the first
record was if you watch the queen movie
whatever they talked about it but they
didn't want to put it out because
they're like why are we looking out at
orchestral song that's this long like
there's no way they're gonna like this
and people love this I'm pretty sure the
song came out in 1975 as well yes yeah I
didn't even know it existed until
Wayne's World it was right away it was
huge mass in the 70s it got like zero
play in the 80s the radios were
basically forced to play this you know
essentially six minute song they didn't
want to play because it was so big yeah
right man
yep but it's an example of how song can
come out in 20 years later yeah become a
number one hit shout out Waynesboro
let's grab some more Super chats T wood
says Portland is in anything like the
rest of Maine Down East Maine but a
republican in 2020 and politically
removed from Portland oh yeah for sure
for sure garages Portland to Maine is
the blue in a red State they may be
broken but the blue infested a lot don't
be violent people absolutely don't be
violent
I think Maine's great I think I talk
about it all the time but I think
Maine's wonderful you spend much time up
there I've gone a couple different times
uh I just find like Coastal Maine and
the architecture there it's just
gorgeous I think it's an underrated
state but I also grew up in New England
so it sort of feels more like home I
love man I went up there with Bill
ottman his family has a little property
up there like a little um like a four
houses and like this little Community
guest Community thing we stayed up there
for a few days right on the Canadian
border man it's so nice gorgeous you see
Canada Noob 431 says had to put my 19
year old cat Butters down this morning
he loved watching chicken City so that
was the last thing he got to watch as he
waited for the vet he was the best cat
thanks for the stream guys sorry to hear
it's already here Butters
we lost it chicken City lost its best
fan day oh 19 years is such a testament
how well you took care of your cat
though that's so true that's that's a
long long life well bogus has been alive
a lot longer than he's supposed to be
how old is he he is going on five I
think he's just over five now and he he
was the doctor said he had a couple
weeks to live in December
he's got a heart defect and he's got
kidney problems because he was a street
cat who was malnourished presumably and
so the kidney medicine is bad for the
heart the heart medicine is bad for the
kidneys we could give him dialysis for
the kidneys but his heart can't handle
it so we're just basically struggling to
maintain balance and his blood levels
are getting out of whack because kidneys
don't work that well but we're giving
him uh hormones to simulate red blood
cell growth so we may have to do
like once the blood levels like nitrogen
or whatever it gets too high like do a
blood transfusion which could kill him
because his heart is no good but we
can't leave his blood in a bad State
I'll just say he's very happy he's been
in good spirits over the past several
months oh yeah he's been living life
he's been gaining weight and he's
survived a lot longer than they thought
he would so that's really that's really
good news but we can't give him fluids
anymore is a big problem with animals
and cats in particular their mood is a
big part of will they survive do they
want them you know humans too the broken
heart death is like just so tragic Steve
houseworth says as a fellow Chicago area
guy you think you'd ever have Mancow on
IRL or culture War he became a huge Free
Speech Advocate even was in the Illinois
governor race yeah that'd be really cool
never even considered having mankow on
we should definitely it's funny because
I feel like he's a Chicago guy do you
guys know Manco no I think it's
syndicated him in Ohio
he's like I don't know what to say huge
in Chicago I don't know if he still is
it's like Howard Stern but in Chicago oh
okay and it's funny he's got Billboards
everywhere I remember my friends telling
me that on the morning of 9 11 they were
on their way to school high school and
Mancow is this like shock jock Morning
Show and then he's like ladies and
gentlemen this is not a joke a plane has
crashed into the World Trade Center and
then they all start laughing in the car
like that man cow is so ridiculous with
his ridiculous show and then he's like
this is not a joke this is serious
another planet's crash and they're all
laughing in the car like this guy's out
of his mind they feel like bring in a
producer and be like no he's not joking
no they went into school and they walked
in they said everyone call your parents
you're going home
yeah that's crazy I guess in Chicago
they would send everyone home a lot some
places did some places didn't something
he's probably dead yeah some schools
brought in TVs and turned the news on
and just made everybody watch it they
said I was I think in kindergarten when
it happened and we all got sent home but
I grew up like two hours two hours
outside of New York so there was like
lots of Panic All Around and people's
parents commute in and stuff like that I
wasn't in school
woke up to the news on the TV the same I
was in Queens and then I had to listen I
didn't have a TV set up because I just
moved to New York City and so I listened
to Howard Stern talk about it for like
three hours it's pretty wild I can smell
it I could see it in Alabama everyone's
uh the real Hydro PX this guy probably
gives us more money in super chats than
any other person sorry Raymond g Stanley
Jr hydro's got you covered he says Tim
you said you would pay five thousand
dollars for any information on who did
the arson you said nothing about the
police pressing charges pay the guy
already actually uh the tweet I put out
specifically said as for legal reasons
information leading to the arrest and
conviction of the the arsonist and
there's very specific legal reasons why
I said it that way and why everyone
always does say it that way
oh I think we got an update well hold on
I just got a notification on Twitter
right now about it I'm trying to find it
where's the stupid notification here we
go it's in here somewhere
a tweet from John Kane
what does he say okay
whoa okay uh Wake County D.A Lauren
Freeman to charge the 2x arsonist with
two counts of misdemeanor injury to real
property and uh John Kane at John M Kane
with a K 1776 put out a response with
the uh the announcement
well there you go uh and so there's a
reason why I said information that leads
to the arrest and conviction because uh
and I'll leave it at that there's
there's a legal reason for for putting
that out as such and additionally I said
earlier Hydro if you paid attention that
I believe the evidence was so
overwhelming that uh it constitutes an
immediate payout of the reward and I am
conferring with legal to properly pay
this reward to the individual Who
provided said information
uh considering I don't know what the
fake outrage over the reward is like
considering I'm putting twenty thousand
dollars into a local DIY skate contest
pretty sure it's not gonna be a big deal
to make sure the guy who's helping bring
an arsonist to Justice gets paid it's
just like the news just broke today and
I'm contacting uh my lawyer to properly
have the funds transferred because I I
don't know how it works with uh with
rewards for for you know criminal
actions and things like that
but uh yeah there you go
what do we got let's grab some more
Super chats
all right
D3 FEC says if Trump is being prosecuted
for actions he did well president why
isn't a republican AG Prosecuting Obama
for terrorism for drawing that Cafe in
Yemen just to show the precedent they
are setting yeah come on we want the
Republicans to do a lot of things they
don't do
however to be fair
you know a lot of people complain about
the republicans in Congress they are
filing uh subpoenas and charges and they
are they're they're working on stuff
you know I'm not I'm not suit I'm not
particularly satisfied with it but it's
only been a few months
it's been almost a year since they
gained control and there have have been
a lot of things that have come out and I
think the Republicans will ramp up in
2024. there is information that seems to
show Joe Biden intentionally intervened
to protect hunter in these criminal
cases which is absolute impeachment
absolute conviction not so much we'll
see
where are we at with these super chats
Jason Dixon said Tim make sure they buy
the correct song there are several fake
copies of a song also got a guest
suggestion how about Raymond Stanley Jr
yes perhaps we'll have him well he's he
works here now yeah today he's so nice
yeah it's official yeah and we
periodically have people come on but uh
you know
uh where are we at yeah shout out he's
the nicest
doing doing doing good work helping make
sure everything's working like our AC
keeps breaking
and simple fixes too it's just nobody
knows how to fix it Justin Green Oliver
Anthony to perform at Blue Ridge rock
festival that that was the best I look
I've been only to a handful of festivals
but Blue Ridge was amazing North
Carolina uh I think it's Virginia okay
I've driven up the parkway it's gorgeous
it kind of invokes scenery ideas huge
massive oh yeah massive and it was super
fun we got to hang out with adelita's
way that was really cool those guys were
awesome seeing them play live that was
amazing those guys can perform yeah dude
Rick's jeans sold out he's so great it's
sold we have a song I did a song with
Adelitas Way that'll be being released
in the next couple months uh we'll let
you know more as as uh the date arises
and it looks like Blue Ridge is sold out
Blue Ridge rock festival 2023 sold out
we went last year right yeah man that
was that was so much fun really great we
got a lot of light in the mud we we are
uh Lucky in that we were gifted uh
industry passes very very lucky because
we're we're good friends with a rock
star who happens to come on the show
periodically into Jesus
well I was talking about Phil
All That Remains performed yeah that's
the other thing we're talking about
doing too hopefully we can um we can hap
it uh uh we can have this happen Fridays
we wanted to bring back music for a long
time we've been talking about it doing a
Friday jam session and uh I was asking
Phil if he would want to do a cassette
with All That Remains and you know we'll
see though so it's up to him I was like
I got an excellent way to convince that
your bandmates to do it money for money
and then he was like he's like okay that
works we'll see it'll be really cool to
have you know him and maybe someone else
perform and and play some music
maybe even adelita's way yeah man those
guys are good they really Trevor dude
yeah
where are we at Dusty Firebirds as I
made a vertical version of the video and
have the official iTunes and his socials
in the description I ask all the
commenters to buy the song Everybody
Gotta Buy Richmond north of Richmond
uh and I hope there's just more comes
out of that I hope there's more
breakthrough artists that are writing
songs like this that are challenging the
machine and speaking to the masses but
more importantly I hope that everyone
buys that song I hope that you buy
things you care but I hope you download
Public Square onto your phone and use
that app to buy from companies that
share your values that's why we have a
whole bunch of that Anthem jerky and
carnivore snacks because not only are
they really good but I'd rather give my
money to people that are doing good
things that care about the future of
this country
I don't want to give my my money to
garbage companies
Jason Hutchinson says creatives are the
only ones that actually pay taxes
everyone else that acquires money
through fake jobs that don't create
anything anyone values or needs is just
paying taxes looted from the creatives
that produce things people value giving
value to money
I'm somewhat confused there are people
who do work to make things and then
there are people who do weird fake jobs
for money and it's always been the case
there's also people that transport stuff
there there are some so
Venezuela is a good example of a country
with fake jobs they artificially
regulate the existence of jobs by saying
a cell phone store may not have a Salem
a Salesman sell the phone and get the
phone from the from the back room to
hand it to the customer
so when you're buying a cell phone I
want to buy a cell phone in Venezuela
there was like six people I had to talk
to just to get the phone because the
government mandates it through
regulation oh that's crazy to create
jobs they create jobs by force doesn't
work yeah it just makes everyone angry
and and crushes the the economic system
yeah
we'll grab some more Jason Dixon says
Trump just said he will turn himself in
Thursday
wow I wouldn't be surprised if the judge
goes the deal for two hundred thousand
dollars Bond rejected remand bangs a
gavel
I'm not saying it will but I'm saying I
would not be surprised about well you
know there you go just because the
prosecution cut a deal on the bond does
not mean the judge accepts it
you guys ever watch Yellowstone yeah
that scene where the environmental
activist cuts the deal and then uh Kevin
Costner is like don't take the deal and
she's like I'm gonna take the deal and
then as soon as she pleads guilty the
judge goes you plead guilty okay I
reject the deal 14 years bang and she's
like what because the prosecution was
like we wanted to serve a year and then
as soon as she pleads guilty the judge
can be like no I'll do whatever I want
mm-hmm yeah too bad that show's getting
canceled I really liked it I know I'm
sad about it did it fail no there's like
Kevin Costner doesn't want to do it oh
wow so they're gonna do uh was it four
sixes or whatever four sixes I think
they're gonna do they actually the
Creator actually owns that ranch I think
it's hilarious and then isn't uh was it
19 20 one of their other ones
1923.23 23. it still has a couple
episodes to go I think yeah but they're
different shows Yellowstone's was it was
a was a really good show the funny thing
is that uh what are they called the
corridor of death in Wyoming Israel yeah
yeah it's never been effectively tested
other than a guy who killed a bull moose
and got charged and then tried claiming
there was no there were jurisdiction yes
well there's no peers right by which the
kind of constitutionally sound trial
there's known to be a jury and then the
federal courts were just like trius and
he was like okay okay I'll take the deal
and the deal it's like slap on the wrist
or see how far we're willing to take
this yeah
I wouldn't try it Nick because I just
finished vivek's interview with Sean
Ryan
oh nice this one sold me I was gonna
vote Trump but I don't believe he'll
step up if he gets in again straight up
I think Vivek could change the world oh
Sean Orion's awesome did you see the
video of a vague playing tennis yeah
I love this guy
it's not it's not a video of the game of
tennis it's just Vivek with no shirt
playing tennis and you can't see who
he's playing against I just thought it
was hilarious man he lays into that
tennis ball too with the tennis Grunts
and all I thought it was funny all right
everybody if you haven't already please
smash that like button subscribe to this
here YouTube channel share the video
share this podcast with your friends
word of mouth is the best way to help
podcasts grow and head over to
timcast.com click join us to become a
member if you want to watch the members
only uncensored show which will be live
in only a few minutes you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast uh Lauren you
wanna shout anything out
hi Dad uh don't know uh catch my show if
you want to I don't know I don't want to
be too driftery but
okay fine you know I don't know so I I
do a show it's on Rumble big dig energy
uh you can just rumble.com forward slash
C forward slash big dick energy dig by
the way dig uh or you can find me on
Twitter it's some uh B I know the B
rhymes with Mitch you know and then the
eye anyways I don't know how often does
your Show come out uh it's three times a
week Tuesday Thursday Saturday uh I had
a lot of computer problems this last
week so I didn't do any of it so there's
not anything recent I updated some
drivers and then everything broke so
that was a good time I don't like
technology either I I am begrudgingly
learning a lot about it
but there big dick energy dot info is
also my website there you go when's the
show go live uh it's Tuesday Thursday
it's at 10 9 Central is when it starts
it's about three hours and it's just me
I I talk for a long time and talk with
the chat and we put together information
so it's like
I don't know that's awesome it's a great
time I love it dude I love doing it I
can't believe I get to do it for a
living to be honest so that's so cool
what's that well it's been fun having
you on I'm Hannah clear brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best uh I actually published my
first op-ed today on timcast.com and it
has to do with Taylor Swift are you guys
surprised absolutely not
um so go check it out if you want to and
also follow the rest of our writers on
social media and on other platforms uh
it's been great I'm uh at HC promo on
Twitter I don't know why I can never
remember that you got it I'm at Ian
Crossland I have really everywhere on
social media follow me on X on minds and
in case you're wondering it is some
I know I didn't know if I could
say that I can now you can say he's been
swearing the whole time I'm feeling it
tonight man I'm not putting the
mask and I've been really trying really
hard not to support us
you did great so I can be a dog it's
some I know but the iron is
the number one okay
they're gonna follow you okay good to
see you thank you I'll catch you guys
tomorrow actually on the after show
actually let's get hot yeah let's get
hot indeed uh Boca Boca will be doing
well in the Rugby World Cup which comes
in September I want to show that uh one
of the persons of chatting wandering
William anyways yeah Boca Boca get your
jerseys everybody we're gonna do well
pleasure having you it's been fantastic
thank you very much yeah and uh let's go
to the after show Tim we will see you
all over at timcast.com in a few minutes
thanks for hanging out